two hello everybody it is Friday a
glorious beautiful June 16th Friday
we are one week out from the live show
crazy crazy crazy times are upon us
cheers my dude cheers who is that what
is that
some guy
late again it's the me myself hold on
hold on Play It Again cheers my dude my
dude what am I missing
it's just a funny sound but I don't know
oh it is just a random guy yeah Oh I
thought I thought it was like an inside
joke that I wasn't getting no we were
calling random people now we've just
been saying it in the office like all
morning so here's my dude sure
[Music]
it's got a little clicking at the end
there you might want to snap well he's
tapping the glass
right it does yeah okay probably still
cut it
um today's episode is sponsored by
Shopify and honey thank you to our
beautiful sponsors thank you sponsors we
love them we're obsessed
now obviously have you been watching
this shows we uh this week's shows
yes so then you know that it's been a
strew of really subpar episodes this
week I disagree wow
the audience I disagree with you're
disagreeing the shows have sucked but
I'm glad to say today uh in front of you
all I make this pledge to you on this
Friday June 16th that today in defiance
of what has been a slew the norm of
terrible unwatchable trash that we put
out on this channel that today
on this Friday Eve
we have a good show plan yeah okay
thank you for always
always the show for me always
um actually we have a really fun so you
guys remember when the crew styled me
um that was a really fun segment so
we're doing it today we're styling Ela
each of the crew put together an outfit
before you the budget was fifty dollars
I see a couple people went over but not
a lot
seems like everyone's pretty much stuck
Zach is way under 22s back that's all
you needed that's all I need really
interesting I came in way under two Dan
came in at 33.
wow I can't wait so this is fun this is
going to look forward to there's lots of
stuff in the uh
and the news here today I want to touch
on
um
check this out I saw this on the
subreddit
Ethan from from
Eaton to Ethan mm-hmm
this one was pretty was pretty crazy
actually it was crazy to see for me as
well
that's crazy yeah it was big but I had
gotten really big I felt like I was
impossible and then I would never lose
the weight
but uh there it is yeah I'm good
thanks
to see we have Jack Sparrow with us
thank you yeah it's nice it's nice to
see you know interestingly I'm still
like I think technically
obese or maybe on the the border of
obese and overweight
yes I don't know how or if Matt is the
clinical term for that
yeah I don't know how you're looking
really good though thank you really
Gabe what's going on why are we doing
Jack Sparrow today
I have an announcement to make yeah
I'm going to change my name Rebrand my
name from white cloud gate to Uncle Gabe
who is Uncle Gabe Uncle Gabe I'm I'm
just sorry White Cloud is not giving me
any anything any incentive even though I
promote their brand I'm making why cost
some money but it's time to move on I'm
renaming myself Uncle Gabe who is Uncle
Gabe okay but wait
effective immediately that's kind of
long maybe just okay effective
immediately so um can we just call you
Uncle Gabe or do we need to say that
whole thing uncle gay Uncle Gabe's fine
Uncle good okay and you are an uncle
right so that is technically true yeah
yeah yeah yeah and it's this and yeah oh
and second of all I'm going to be
launching my merch in a couple of weeks
Uncle Sam watch out for that
I'll keep a lookout for that Gabe
um is this outfit part of the Rebrand
what is going on here yeah I was
wondering that I just want to say
Rebrand Jack Daniels this is like a
welcoming committee wait yeah sweet my
God
it is I keep trying to like these bobos
but it's like wait what did you get
mocha you got an ice blend I got
whatever Olivia gets
it's so sweet I mean it's good but oh my
God you know yeah they're all different
flavors
it tastes similar but this one's more
thicker or something it's Blended
so you got the new outfit
yeah Pirates of the Caribbean or
something Jack Jack Daniels yeah Daniels
and is this going to be your new Jack
Daniels [__] Uncle [__]
and um are you gonna be wearing this
kind of outfits from now on
um maybe Halloween okay so you won't be
dressing like that every day
well why not just opening to a new brand
um
Reinventing and stuff
I think you should dress like that
because
I think The Branding could help as a
holistic Uncle Gabe type of thing uncle
Gabe it's a heavier drink are you gonna
be drinking Jack Daniels like every
Friday now
mm-hmm Jack Daniels is good it's a big
life decision I feel like to go from
white clothes to Jack Daniels that's
yeah
are you gonna keep drinking white
clothes are you out
um probably probably not not anymore wow
this is a big change for you and the
show I gotta say yeah you're not you
know reaching out to me they don't want
me I hear the the Trump one of my
management tried to reach out to them
and they didn't want me so [__] [__]
it I'm oh okay they gave you the effect
they gave you an official answer they
said we do not want to partner with him
they didn't want to [__] you know
didn't want to give me a deal even
though I helped promote the brand
Parkway claw dude [__] it I can't
imagine how many would run to Uncle Gabe
I can't imagine how many games sold for
them I don't think I knew what white
claw was neither I still I saw Uncle
Gabe the first time I went to a
bachelorette party
um and they asked me what do I want to
drink I was like let's get a white claws
Gabe Uncle Gabe you literally put white
Claw on the map who the [__] are they
without Uncle Gabe and who the [__] is
Uncle Gabe okay that's my brand
of the game
[__] [__] I feel like this Uncle
Gabe is a little more serious I'm
getting like there's a more serious
Stone
because he's been scorned he's more
business-like now yeah he's fallen snake
Gabe yeah
uh Uncle Gabe maybe we should start our
own uh spritzer or seltzer during the
combat them and put them out of business
yeah
maybe we'll call it fat dad
[__] [__] [__] [__]
I'm pissed about white Club
I hope they I hope they go out of
business for that
are they publicly traded who owns White
Club
who I don't know I'll tell you I was
just one dude I'm not gonna say his name
because I actually don't want to um I'm
not trying he's a billionaire though
wait wait his whole thing is white claw
hard Seltzer he made a he turned into a
billionaire from this [__]
wow it's the number one Seltzer in the
US with 58 of the market share holy [__]
dude you did that Gabe he can't Pony out
like he's a billionaire he can't kick do
a little Kickback for for Uncle Gabe
After all you've done you know a brand
deal nothing so that's not cool
they say like I I hear one of my the
management teams they say I curse too
much but [__] it's a beer it's an
alcohol it's all alcohol
talking about we're not selling Disney
movies it's alcohol you know what people
do on alcohol
you curse too much that makes people
want to spend great alcohol that's part
of the brand you know you know what
people do when they drink alcohol [__]
they crash they drive drunk they do
horrible things they have sex it's not
it's not a wholesome drug I did
everything right and they indicted me
[__] that's [__] so
you know what so I'm leaving I'm leaving
the name and going to Uncle Gabe Uncle
Gabe's Universal
and see why how it goes yeah I mean it
couldn't be worse
it'll be worse than how they're treating
you now I will say this
um
yeah I'm not happy about this not happy
about it I'm [__] pissed about it
it's just obscene
I'm annoyed with this kind of big
companies saying all these stupid
statements like what what's next they're
gonna say oh you can't have tattoos yeah
it's like what you can't have blue hair
right
oh what you can't be a man right
who's controlling who they're coming for
us men
all right gay well are you going to be
changing like your Tick Tock name and
your Twitter name and your PA and your
uh uh Cameo name and all that pretty
much so so if you don't want to record
just say uncle game Uncle Gabe
who is Uncle Gabe who is Uncle Gabe all
right who is Uncle Keith so who is good
so who is Gabe who is Gabe who is Gabe
all right listen
is dead to me white cloth [__] you how
about that for cursing [__] [__] [__]
you [__] white Club [__]
I never liked that [__] anyway YouTube
doesn't like when you say that on my
dick right and yeah
I still have to do it at home
um
beat the [__] out of you [__] right
just for the Devils for the demons yeah
I learned it from Uncle game well I'm
sorry about that
and the Jack Sparrow outfit is unrelated
that's just what you're doing today yeah
got it look good and don't forget I have
merch drop it off in a couple weeks go
check it out I won't forget this um
uncle game Uncle game
unclegabe.com
something like that oh we don't even
know the URL we'll find it we'll figure
it out yeah
dropping soon in a couple weeks go check
it out we will okay where do we go check
it out I think it might be unclegabe.com
but we're not sure okay we'll work on
getting the URL for us next week so we
can know where to buy it all right yeah
Gabe how's your sword play
my short play
this is my sword this is kind of like
the sword right here your your dogs your
hands
in my hands instead of oh wow kind of
like my brass knuckle right there [__]
laughs
someone asked Uncle with k or with c
what kind of question is that
yeah you got me this week you did good
walk the plank matey mate
what's on your ring what is that ring
it's like a little cake
Oh wow was it a cake it's a stone
it's a stone what's up with the with the
orange rose on it okay we love that all
right Gabe you have a great weekend [__]
white blood
never again never again
all right dude Uncle Gabe signing out
we'll see you next week
next week next week actually I'll be
seeing him in person all day next week
is the live show game
you'll be there with us right
sure well live show
I'll make sure there's I'll tell the bar
is there a bar there
uh yeah about the sure
he doesn't like to commit sure you are
coming you didn't yeah you're coming
right because like you're like part of
the show okay all right sure right on
but I'll tell the bar no white clothes
all right thanks Gabe we'll see you next
week buddy love you
[Applause]
[Music]
there is Uncle game
I support the Rebrand I mean to be
honest though yeah that is a massive
lost opportunity for those idiots
totally what morons
he could have been your Jared from
Subway minus the
all the other controversy that came with
that
which I don't need to list here today of
course
but so um let's see I want to talk about
pearly dis everyone is still typing
crashing
okay wait we got a video somebody took a
video right we have that I'd like to see
so here's what I want to do regarding
the crashing
tweet the video to YouTube and then
we'll all comment under it and I'll show
you guys what it looks like it's not
interesting it's just they're watching
the app and then it closes because they
keep acting like I'm [__] lying about
it
here's the tweet in question
so where's the uh video I'm grabbing it
unless you already have it you want to
tweet it from the podcast account sure
right I'll do that right now
do the crashing is insane so they're
just watching it
yeah and then the app just totally
closes so there's no message there's no
error there's no warning just buy
who wants to watch like that
so let me open I'm surprised that
YouTube is not
aware
they act like I'm [__] lying I swear
to God it's insane
well it's on YouTube there are term
s
um okay well let me know when that's up
and we can we can Brigade that there but
yeah I wanted to talk about
um
look at my muscle in that picture you
feeling good about that
just looks pretty good
nice nice uh
nice tone
nice shape little bulge here a little
bit of a bulge
nice shading
good color
forearms are looking juicy
nice
put those guns away man
scare me
I'm tweeting this at Team YouTube yeah
like should I do it where their name is
at the beginning so it's like at them
yeah yeah wait wait if you do it that
way they'll less people see it yeah you
can just tweet it out like normal okay
here's what the video looks like they
were tweeting them and thank you to
whoever did this uh user
Giovanni rules too
HD proof that crash gate is not a hoax
I was starting to think maybe people are
just [__] with me I was like is Crash
the new audio audio
right because it doesn't happen to me
well here take a look
here they are just having a good time
watching our stream everybody's having
fun
you know he's participating
he's chatting he types oh no oh no the
he's a active yeah in the audience
he's having such a good time laughing
giggling
the best best time he's having
and uh as you see here
as the chat zips on by
two types by
and then it crashes
hmm
and there it is he has to reopen the app
so send that to them I don't know what
else they want from me they go send me
screenshots it's like of what the app
crashing what are you asking for
you want to screenshot of my face going
like oh this is me when the app crashed
ah
I'm being told that's his actual that's
his actual face I'm so sorry fine arack
sorry
so let me go to Twitter
you guys posted it
[Music]
let me just comment on it
and uh
here I'll comment on my main account
sorry that we have to do this but
they're just not fixing it
[Music]
please fix your [__] please help we are
dying out here good men good men and
women
why do the good always
I don't know
please help me we are dying out here
good men and women D-Day right Dan D-Day
uh yeah yeah close enough Deez Nuts Deez
Nuts
[Music]
all right so I want to talk about pearly
just pearly things
obviously we had a quite a conversation
[Music]
another
yeah people people make comparisons with
uh
there was a moment when she said Ethan
and I was like oh we got another one it
wasn't okay you can but it was God I was
hoping so it was close it was close
someone put a album together of all the
their faces when they're like at their
most I guess frustrated or defeated can
you call that post up
yeah we could make like our own trading
card deck oh yes
you know all your Pokemons
so just early things uh she's been
coping hard which we didn't really get
to talk about yesterday but I think
we'll be hold on one second Ethan your
camera's frozen we're fixing it real
quick all right
oh wait there we go no I would love to
catch up on it because oh my God I was
listening and like it's one of those
episodes where I can't go one second
without like talking out loud to myself
or to the phone yeah you know I listened
to it back and even I was getting
frustrated because she's saying so much
[__] I didn't get an opportunity to
respond to all of it but a lot of it I
was like man I wish I addressed that I
wish I addressed this because it just
it's all just such [__] yeah
but here is the uh I'll put I have yeah
this is
she was having a hard time that day I
don't know why poor Jeff's got to be in
here but yeah I guess he's the original
okay Ethan I don't think Jeff's a good
man but yeah okay we love Jeff he is has
his own story yeah he has his own story
um
Sebastian who could forget
our favorite uh with the Mark Elliot
with the footage over him apparently
hold on still free of tourettes to this
day
watch his 12-part documentary about how
he did that at next time brainwashed
YouTube channel
Holly London who maybe is still the
biggest piece of [__] because I feel
like
Pearl is like a meme she's almost
unbelievable when you come out and be
like oh yeah women shouldn't have the
right to vote women should uh all
abortion should be illegal then you're
like okay what are you for real but
Ollie is
he's a real [__] demon but is does
Pearl get a lot of views on some stuff
she blew up because on Tick Tock and on
YouTube she started doing videos with
fresh and fit and Andrew Tate and doing
that whole thing yeah so she started
getting a bunch of views because she's
like a token yeah you know what I mean
a token female
big time
but um
so she's been coping really hard it's
quite good it's quite good
I know Taylor wanted to comment on that
yeah so
let's go mom you want to join us Taylor
I know you had some comments on the way
here I was driving with Taylor
and I I really wanted to catch up hold
on hold on hold on there's too many
people talking
I want to make sure that they can hear
you
okay go ahead
so yeah
well just
go ahead you learn so on the way here I
was driving with Taylor and I needed to
catch up on the ending because you guys
mentioned the crazy slavery coming I was
like I have to catch up on that yeah so
I happen to be listening to it while I
was driving with Taylor and she had a
lot of thoughts on that one yeah
actually she shared a few with me that I
thought were interested so I was like I
was like do you mind saying it on the
podcast because I feel like we need to
hear your opinion here yeah yeah I mean
she has 1.5 million Subs on YouTube but
to be honest her views are all over the
place like not 1.5 million yeah that's
true but here's one from one day ago
with 1.8 thousand
huh one day ago this is her best
performing one twenty thousand if you go
to popular it's a wide range if you go
to popular her most uh viewed ones it's
just Andrew Tate Andrew Tate you know
I'm a 10. look at this girl she thinks
she's a 10. [__] Jordan Peterson I red
pilled my friend I don't know but
actually interestingly she's live right
now and the topic of conversation is is
body positivity a good thing let's take
a listen
uh let me guess what their uh conclusion
is no
he's going to talk about lizard
these plus size models are starting to
excuse me are you really having a
conversation with this [__] badass
here
like just be real about this this guy is
not talking about body positivity is he
drop off there was this Latina this
guy's the biggest [__] when she was 37
years old she died from heart heart
attack yeah and the number one reason
people die in the world is due to
circulatory issues wow
and you're consuming too much food
you're vain yes we know being we know
it's unhealthy to be super broken and
everything they actually get uh clogged
up with excess amounts of food you're a
skinny person that's just I mean he
looks so unwell this guy like genuinely
so when you talk about markers of Health
that's what I'm trying to say is like
the larger girls that one marker of
Health in regards to circulatory health
is going to be lower low [__] dumbass
that's not what body positivity means
okay all right well I might be speaking
at a turn about this guy maybe he's
there to uh defend the fatties like
myself Ethan you're getting yeah you're
getting yeah you're getting two I might
be getting there oh my God yeah I don't
know if you can use that word the
fatties but I might not I don't know I
mean I'm still obese technically
I just don't know if you can use the
hard app
I think you might be right
I think I might have staged out of it
sounded kind of rude [__]
I could see how you could be confused
because people still call you fat all
the time online that's the first thing
they say about you so well what they
seem to think and maybe I agree once a
fatty always a fatty right even if you
lose the weight you're still fat you
know what I mean like you did that you
were fat for that time and that's on you
forever we will never forget you got a
fat mindset I'm tired I'm sweaty I'm fat
I'm overweight
all right let's go back to what we were
talking yeah let's go back to what we're
talking about so I want to show you a
few clips of the cope or do you want to
go ahead sorry Taylor you want to
comment yeah go ahead well let's do you
want to say what she said in case
anybody has not watched it what what
Pearl said about slavery
sure that's a good idea I mean I love
watching that clip it's so insane yeah I
just think it because because I watched
like almost all of it but I had to catch
up on that ending yeah let's watch it
again I mean I love going back home
especially that part it's just it's
absolutely Bonkers dude
let's see
because that's that's literally they
they the founder of or the guy who made
Roots said I wanted a myth for my people
to live by so they often but that's what
they do is they embellish and I'm not
trying to say it wasn't horrible it was
right but they want to make it like more
horrible so that they can control people
yeah can you get the link to to ours
because that's when she talks about
um
she was reading letters from slaves and
all this kind of crazy nonsense
uh but go ahead Taylor you can yeah make
your point people know well I mean like
it's not that there's not
historical text
of first-hand accounts of slavery there
are but like five percent at one point
it was only like maybe five percent of
people of color and enslaved people were
able to even be literate it was
literally illegal
teach a person of color to read or write
so
by that standard that's saying that
there's like
so few first-hand accounts about what
was really happening during that time so
to say that it's like over exaggerated
is so blatantly wrong and it's if
anything grossly under exaggerated
there's so much that we don't know well
she did hedge your bet she says well
some was exaggerated and some was under
exaggerated right and it's like okay
sides
both sides have good points yeah it
doesn't make any sense I was I was
completely over her entire
argument
well your point is actually a good one
about because such a small percentage of
slaves were allowed to learn to read and
write and the ones that did like
Frederick Douglass were like turned out
to be great Scholars and activists the
idea that slaves went and learned to
read and write and then when they did
that they're like I'm gonna write a nice
letter about my master oh my master my
great experience we love George yeah
like no Daddy George he's the goodies Oh
Daddy George
that's crazy actually I'm
I always get signed out of chat GPT but
I wanted to ask it a few things you know
what I mean yeah she really did keep
harping on like they're so like there's
so many different experiences and
accounts it's some of it is
embellishment but you're so right it's
like all of the historical information
is so undersaturated because
there is no there is none where like
yeah was she there did she how does she
know so much about their experience
Pearl oh my God
it's frustrating that she even feels the
need to talk about that point because
okay even if there are a couple letters
that doesn't mean that what happened was
okay so what's the point of even talking
about this well it's this what are you
trying to say you know like what what's
the undertone here that we're trying to
say are we trying to say that something
was okay it's horrible
I was so close to getting her to say
this and I wish I asked her but I know
this was just on the tip of her tongue
that some slaves were better off with
their masters than they were freed like
I was I'm so sure that she was just
about to say that right I mean it was
right there she was right there
yeah that was her attitude about women
too it's like oh there's no there's no
pay Gap they're just lazy mm-hmm
yeah she's a wild one
she's a wild one but yeah that was a
really good point about that I wanted to
Source how you can ask chat gbt is there
any letters written by slaves that
praise their masters I'm curious
you know is there even one
let's find out
apparently she's read a whole uh
anthology of slave letters
uh talking about how great their daddy
George is
[Music]
yeah um but as they're coping here is
what they shoot immediately went on the
her podcast
and started talking to this guy who is
so unhealthy looking
clogged you man he's clogged up his
chakras are all blocked bro
this man's been retaining his semen for
too long so let it out brother
it's not worth it you know okay so chat
gbt said there is but you have to
consider that uh they were afraid of
speaking badly about them right you have
to take into context that uh yeah
they're doing as a precaution like duh
but were there a lot of them
they said a few instances
yeah that's what I would imagine a few
instances that makes a lot of sense yeah
and they're like man if my master finds
us they're gonna literally kill me
my Master's awesome he's the best
yes sir a few incidents where enslaved
individuals wrote letters or narratives
that spoke kindly of their masters or
expressed gratitude however it's
essential to approach these accounts
with costume and understand the context
in which they were written
during the time of slavery enslaved
individuals often face severe
repercussions for speaking out against
their masters or criticizing the
institution of slavery many slave
narratives that have survived were
written or dictated with the assistance
of abolition abolitionists or
sympathetic white individuals okay
that's interesting so it was dictated
who may have influenced the content to
appeal to White audience or to avoid
backlash that makes sense right yeah oh
one example is The Narrative of
Frederick Douglass an influential
African-American
abolitionist and former slave
in his first autobiography The Narrative
of the Life of Frederick Douglass an
American slave Douglas acknowledged that
some slave holders were relatively kind
and treated their slaves with less
cruelty however he also emphasized that
any benevolence or kindness demonstrated
by slaveholders did not excuse or
Justify the institution of slavery
itself obviously yeah Stockholm syndrome
too
uh
uh yeah I yeah but okay another example
is the account of Harriet Jacobs an
African-American writer and former slave
in her autobiography incidents in the
life of a slave girl Jacobs expressed
gratitude towards a kind and sympathetic
mistress who taught her how to read and
sew that does seem extraordinarily uh
unusual to teach her to read and so
however she also revealed the overall
oppressive nature of slavery and the
detrimental effect it had on her life
yeah obviously and that's what I said to
her it's like you I'm sure there were
times where the Masters and slaves had
good relationships right that doesn't
mean that slavery she's like a walking
country exaggerated because also when
you talked about some things and she was
like why are you focusing on the
exceptions it's like girl you are
talking about the exception right now
it's all she every time she talks about
something it's the exception she talks
about women lying women lying about
abuse how many times does that happen
those are the exceptions most women
don't lie about their abuses they were
actually abused the vast majority why
are you talking about exceptions ladies
he yeah she sucks she's a dumbass
and um well I'm glad we had that combo
because and I loved hearing her talk
about how women have too many choices
when it comes to pregnancy that's true
like what choice exactly because I'm the
only one that can carry a baby if I
could choose I choose you carry it
you know you carry it no you carry it I
would carry it if I could trust me right
I would make this burden on
but like as long as it's my body yeah
I'm gonna choose I'm gonna choose what
I'm gonna do with my body
well and then also it's like just put on
a condom men can't do have the choice to
wear a condo yeah wear a condom that's
it tie off your balls whatever it is
that yeah get a vasectomy you know don't
take any risk right if you're so afraid
of having a baby
um but here is this pasty uh sickly
looking gentleman uh responding to the
the live right afterwards
and we're just sitting at home and like
what did I do
Centric thing but a lot of young white
guys are feeling bad for being white
they're just like yeah you're bad
because you're white you're like dude
she went straight she went straight from
slavery was uh exaggerated to White four
white men are just having the hardest
time
perfect segue
concerned I'm like 17 and I like Call of
Duty and it's like all of the the like
the Matrix and the Matrix in the media
anyone who says Matrix unironically has
no credibility in anything they ever
talk about you can't be serious
The Matrix you're talking about the
movie that was written by like two trans
women right no
no that's the movie you're talking about
it was written by two trans women you
know that right
um I know it's I know it's Inconvenient
Truth but it is what it is what are they
pushing and that's the crazy thing like
I just got out of him where they were
literally
women should sleep on as opposed to
being virgin I mean she's such a coward
for even trying to describe it like that
but okay whatever say whatever you want
dummy yeah like they it's like what what
are you pushing you're pushing for
promiscuity which isn't good for women
yeah
what does she know that's good for women
I don't know she's a walking billboard
for like all of her failure
according to her she's literally trying
to blame all of her failures on women as
a whole she's trying to make us take
credit for them but it's like no I'm
actually I'm a lot of the stuff that
you're talking about I'm actually pretty
good at no yeah I don't know I don't
know what exactly you're talking about
but um don't drag me down with you
please I mean it's all she's obviously
just like the biggest Pickney ever yeah
she's trying to be a part of their club
by trashing on all women being a token
and the hopes that one of them uh
ends up thinking she's cool enough too
right with that she's trying to find a
partner this way I don't know well it's
I feel so bad because it has not yet
when she's working very very hard on
that but she the guys who go on the show
are very high value they're not going to
settle for her
right and she's admitted that yeah very
high value that guy out and they're the
guys who are on the show are all super
high value by their according to that
yeah yeah not survive but when would we
ever rank anybody as high value ever
I've never thought of anybody as low or
high valve no I mean that that term in
itself is quite cringy yeah it's all
wrong I look in the mirror every morning
and I say out there is a medium value
man
it could be worse yeah
my if I play my cards right I might be
able to settle for a Girl Like Pearl
she goes I'll be happy to get married at
all
like okay Gilead [__] she's straight
up one of these uh
right the house the wives from yeah who
like you should be happy if you're in a
marriage
dude you never get to divorce that's her
perfect world I mean it kind of who was
it that we were watching that was saying
indoor if there is him it's this guy oh
it is this is the indoor guy that is the
indoor yeah okay oh my God is that
awesome but wait he has Choice words for
me here okay weapons of mass destruction
so he went against the Matrix and now
bro Stop It Go Back start over remake
that point you're seriously wearing a
suit and a tie and talking about the
Matrix you look like agent Smith fit
and also you're holy [__]
and also like agent Smith you're a clone
you're one of like a thousand other
identical morons oh my God
the whole new layer of irony that's
amazing and you know what if the what if
the Matrix was real I wish that they
would [__] tape his mouth shut like
that nightmare of Neos oh yeah Major
Smith tapes his mouth shut yeah yeah
that's creepy scene that'd be a cool
podcast I'd watch that just you sitting
there silently thank you Andrew was
smart enough to know
that there are literally hundreds of
millions by the way this is called
Andrew Tate emergency meeting
live there's some franchise young man
who were tired of being [__] on social
media okay person you're a rapist I I
went to the they all say Grapist by the
way what is that because they don't want
to say the r word they say Grapist
okay
um
here I lost the time
now now I'm a great impressionable young
men who are just sitting at home so here
he is I'm like what did I do like a lot
of these young guys and this is an
American eccentric thing but a lot of
young white guys are feeling bad for
being white they're just like yeah
you're bad like dude my name's Spencer
and I'm like 17 and I like Call of Duty
yeah and it's like all of the the like
the Matrix Matrix in the media what are
they talking about ever and that's the
crazy thing like I just got off a stream
where they were literally pushing that
women should sleep around as opposed to
being virgins yeah it's like what are
you pushing you're pushing for
promiscuity which isn't good for women
yeah and it's not and it's not good
sorry I had gone I was just gonna say
sorry sorry I didn't mean to cut you off
sir also the men should get the yeah
yeah I respect you you remember when you
asked you were like how come you're not
supposed to sleep around as a woman and
she was like heartbreak oh yeah like
that was the dumbest answer that's the
argument you're standing on oh my God
yeah thank you for bringing that up I
was like that was painful my jaw dropped
when she said what a dumb response you
just told on yourself so hard I mean you
can get heartbroken without having sex
dummy mama that's a personal answer I
don't think you should be debating about
women's rights I think you should go to
therapy talk about yourself I think the
the true dialogue tree is this which you
failed to communicate well because she's
not very bright or good at this right
the true dialogue tree is this
when you have sex with lots of people
it desensitizes your ability to pair
bond
they love that phrase they do what's
that so when you have sex with a lot of
people it
it numbs you to pair bonding which means
the more people you have sex with the
less
significant your bond will be with your
next Partners you won't be able to love
again you know and interesting that does
not apply to men
I think she's thinking like werewolves
who like like in Twilight when they was
it called Olivia imprinting I know
exactly imprint they can only imprint on
one person for the rest of their lives
Perfect Analogy they're all imprinted on
tape
she's been spiraling ever since that's
true
so anyway here's here's my boy and that
stream is a fat Los Angeles getting
divorced by his wife I'm sorry I'm gonna
say the guy running that stream is a fat
loser who's getting divorced by his wife
what what context well I mean is that
awesome oh my God I mean like wrong and
wrong
well
they can't deal with the fact that I'm
in a like a high cloggy we're in a happy
relationship we're not getting divorced
and he's losing weight so bro you need
to exfoliate or something I don't know
how are you gonna unclog though
maybe he needs to try like um
what's the what's that uh
that thing that's all the craze in uh
Dermatology right now uh the serum it's
uh
um retinol
is really good for that kind of blotchy
[__]
very blotchy yeah but they can't deal
with the fact that I'm in like a happy
marriage with kids and stuff which is
what their idea of a perfect
this is what you're preaching on we have
been in that yeah
and who are you to even talk about this
kind of stuff I don't even understand by
the way even before I had money okay
I know that [__] with your whole Theory
but I got
a gold digger
I got married when I was broke
the V sound there's always going to be
something
I mean jeez that's a long con that's a
really long con we have two kids man
also she's a citizen she's been a
citizen for a while yeah that was my
plan it's the long time yes
um
yeah but they have to create this myth
that uh are uh much like in The Roots
series
I'm sorry just quoting her
um that I'm getting divorced so pretty
interesting stuff yeah I'm not even I
don't
need what mission do these people push
and it's like when somebody what is your
mission she has none
her mission is to for hopefully one dude
out there somewhere to think she's cool
enough to maybe enter a relationship
with
the
Andrew Tate is the MLK of white and
saddles
he has a dream for us and so the meaning
of the term info we dream of a world
with enforced monogamy because Andrew
we can't get laid if it's not Forest
help us daddy Andrew
somebody who genuinely influences yeah
the youth you know genuinely yes young
men and indeed some women in a way that
nobody has ever done before I mean this
is nobody has ever influenced the young
before nobody has ever done this sir I'm
doing pranks on YouTube videos
tick tocks or something this is somebody
who has who has genuine engines
I got indicted I did everything
perfectly and they indicted me this [__]
is so unwatchable I mean what the [__]
dude I did everything right and they
indicted me
yeah this guy why does that sound like a
parody it's slowed down
there's a little pig shift although the
real one sounds like a parody too it
does yeah you could play that I did
everything right and they indicted me
they indicted me
I'd be indicted baby
guided me indicted me
it was the day I was on the high seas
and the Navy approached my vessel they
served me with an indictment
I said he walked the prick
hard to tell
it's one of those dudes that looks like
old and young at the same time
probably too old to be talking like that
oh God damn yeah that's what I'm
wondering so that's what's going on with
them
um
there's one more Pearl take here from
this live stream and a bunch of tweets
too they're all really good uh L3 prank
um he insulted Hindu for views
did Andrew tayden salt and do for views
she doesn't know what L3 is go with the
times dummy did Andrew insulted what did
I do you know what that mean I don't
know what that means unless I don't know
what that is
um okay whatever
got her I guess so here after the debate
ended she went uh directly to Twitter to
start coping and seething
as that's usually what happens after
these hey Twitter world this is yours
truly uh she said getting divorced
should be illegal and I'll stand on this
hill and die on this hill
you should work it out Point Blank
period endure you anymore it's about
your children
okay you have no kids you've never been
married shut your mouth
let's thank our sponsors because we're
way over and then we'll continue with
the Pearly just barely Tings
just pearly things
so thank you first of all to our
wonderful sponsor Shopify
love Shopify man
oh you can feel the beat
hey
yo Shopify is changing the game of
e-commerce and I
uh
I gotta tell you
Penny fresh wouldn't exist without
Shopify nope just wouldn't but not
uh we made teddy fresh on Shopify since
the first day and it's been one of the
best things we ever did
the capability of their platform
you can do it from day one they have
templates to make it super easy you
could do it by yourself and then from
there they have all the tools you know
to build it into a massive multi-billion
dollar company which a lot of them are
on Shopify yes they've got the tools
they got the plugins they have the
professionals to help you it is truly
the most intuitive software too I didn't
know anything about Web building
um you don't need to know you don't need
to know coding you don't need you know
yeah you don't need to come with past
knowledge no it's very intuitive and
very scalable start small and like you
can build it up as much as you need
that's the best part is when you're
ready when you have ideas you're like oh
I want to do this I want to change this
do this then you work with
a programmer and then you can still do
whatever you want from there it's 100
scalable yeah it's the e-commerce
platform revolutionizing millions of
businesses worldwide whether you're
selling uh
this or that
Shopify simplifies selling online and in
person so you can focus on successfully
growing your business Shopify covers
every sales channel from an in-person
POS system to an all-in-one e-commerce
platform it even lets you sell across
social media markets like Tick Tock
Facebook and Instagram packed with
industry-leading tools ready to ignite
your gross Shopify gives you a complete
control over your business and your
brand without having to learn any new
skills or design or code yep and thanks
to their 24 7 help and an extensive
Business course Library Shopify is there
to support your success every step of
the way I'll give one example
when we started our business like you
you start you don't know anything about
anything
and we realized maybe I don't know six
months after starting the business that
there was people doing like crazy fraud
on us yes they were stealing credit
cards this credit card frauds that are
happening and yeah go ahead they were
stealing credit cards sending it all to
the same address and it took us so long
to realize what was happening but they
managed to steal like ten thousand
dollars of merch from us and then I went
to the Shopify store
and I found a prod a fraud prevention
app free
installed it you can customize the
parameters a little bit instantly
resolve the issue yeah it Flags you the
ones that are potential fraudulent it
can freeze them until you you know
there's all kinds of ways to to tackle
it but if I was like building my own
website that would be like a super
complicated issue yeah but it stopped it
in its tracks dead
yeah
I love Shopify I also always like to add
that for us as
um YouTubers influencers there's a lot
of people who would like to mess with
our website but we've never had any
security problems never one never never
went down yeah never no it's a very
secure
now is your turn to get serious about
selling and trying Shopify today this is
possibility powered by Shopify we've got
a great deal for you sign up for a one
dollar per month trial period at
shopify.com after dark all lowercase go
to shopify.com after dark to take your
business to the next level today
shopify.com after dark thank you to our
wonderful sponsor I hope you guys will
consider uh supporting them if you're in
the market thank you
and finally the one the only the great
honey
my next favorite today's episode is
sponsored by PayPal honey the easy way
are we supposed to put something on the
screen Dan you got that
[Music]
uh or not that isn't there some thing
they wanted us to write on the screen
not until next week oh next week okay
today's episode is brought to my PayPal
honey the easy way to save when shopping
on your iPhone or computer
iPhone PayPal is one of these
transformative Services it's free to use
what'd I say PayPal oh PayPal honey yeah
yeah it's free to use it's super easy to
install it's an extension on your
browser and it is such a quality of
Lifesaver it's so fantastic you are
gonna absolutely
regret every day you didn't have this
installed uh manual featuring searching
for coupon codes is a thing of the past
free shopping tool that scours internet
for promo codes and applies the best one
it finds automatically to your cart at
checkout imagine you're shopping at one
of your favorite sites so when you click
check out the honey button appears and
all you have to do is Click apply
coupons wait a few seconds as honey
searches for coupons you can find for
that site and if honey finds a working
coupon you will watch the price drop
automatically and dare I say magically
look at all these savings ELO that
you've racked up
look at these are mostly for Mila right
right 400 dollars
a hundred dollars
sixty dollars these are usually based on
a percentage most of these were not me
not expecting it to happen two hundred
dollars
Postmates [__] twelve dollars it's I'm
telling you it's non-stop with this [__]
you never even know what to expect with
this
and what's exciting is that honey
doesn't just work on desktop it works on
your iPhone now too so just activate it
on Safari on your phone and you can save
on the go
so if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting this show thank you
okay PayPal honey for free at
joinhoney.com after dark that's
joinhoney.com after dark thank you thank
you thank you to our wonderful sponsors
thank you
please uh consider supporting them
you so desire
I have some interesting breaking news
that I think you will really find uh
go ahead I'm pretty compelling here I'm
gonna drop a link right now
switch wait what wait hold on xqc Twitch
star signs 100 million dollar deal with
rival platform a character wait which
platform kick
100 million they give him 100 million
he's ditching twitch
a hundred million
100 million over two years what is crazy
okay what the only thing that tells me
is how [__] obscenely wealthy they
are with disgusting gambling crypto
games like this money is blood money
yeah this is so vile and I guarantee you
here's what's gonna happen mark my words
kick was started by steak because of
which banned gambling okay now that he's
on stake or on Kick I bet you part of
his agreement is that he has to gamble
makes perfect sense and because he was
already making a [__] load of money from
gambling right and I think this was like
rushed as well because twitch just made
an update to its uh Revenue split it's
no longer 50 50 they're gonna do it 70
30. but there is 70 30. no it it's been
50 50. I don't know what it was Prior
Subs yeah for Subs wasn't the higher end
always 70 30 on Twitch there's a couple
of streamers who has a high tier
contracts with twitch but ours for 70 30
I think when we worked with them yeah
okay that's yeah I got it but I'll say
this I'll say this all YouTube
uh members for everybody is 70 30. right
I'd be happy if it was a little better
for me because we do bring a lot of guac
but hey everybody gets the same deal
cheers my dude 100 million that is
shocking
so that's what it is I don't think this
is just like a straight up uh
Talent deal he's gonna have to gamble
he's going to be gambling
what has he been doing on Twitch
like he was gambling and then he stopped
he started again
and everyone was like dude what a
[__] hypocrite because he was being
like I shouldn't have done that and then
when he started again twitch Bandit and
so then he just had to stop and he
famously said by the way when they
banned it and just for the record guys
I've always been against this he said
that
remember that
yeah
wow I mean listen 100 million dollars
for two years I mean I could say nothing
easy
also with hooks like [__] up every
single month like degrading the website
more and more every month I I kind of
understand jumping ships it's even more
lucrative
yeah I don't know this is pretty wild a
hundred I mean the world gets paid like
at this level like top athletes top
athletes I mean but that's crazy for two
years though I don't think there's many
athletes that make 50 million I feel
like it would be like a four-year deal
yeah they usually have like a five
year deal with that much money
like what athletes make 50 million
dollars a year from their
from their org that's insane
holy [__]
on the twitch most popular streamer said
on Friday that he was joining rival
streaming platform kick
uh
uh 70 million dollar contract with
incentives that could push oh my God I'm
gonna about to [__] and piss his agent
is Ryan Morris what a [__] nightmare
whoa whoa holy [__] I cannot believe
that I made it
that's great that is crazy and you know
Ryan probably sneaked a percentage out
of him on that one too
well even if he I mean what's standard
for agent right ten percent he says well
this is 10 million dollars it's still a
pretty good day oh his Asian agent oh
yeah God
I guess yeah somebody else no it's it's
him ten percentage I remember he was
working in Esports stuff and was like
quote managing
wow
yeah this guy almost ruined my [__]
life
he's he he is I'm just saying this is my
opinion uh of course it's my opinion uh
based on my experience with him he is
the most incompetent worst bad faith
[__] up of an attorney that almost
ruined my life yeah it was our worst
time
well he's transitioned into something
he's much better at apparently
because that's a hell cheers my dude
that's a hell of a deal I think that's
more a xqc thing that a Ryan Morrison
well he's his agent he negotiated it xqc
was not negotiating this guarantee
that guy the Apple guy hey I got it
oh man
yeah that guy [__] us so bad I mean I
can't even emphasize how bad he [__]
me
um but there it is
he made it good for him I guess it seems
like a lot of people don't have any idea
what you're referring to they don't know
the war oh back during the fupa fun [__]
I mean it's so long ago now
he was somewhat involved in everything
that happened with your first lawsuit
back then it'd be a lot to explain it's
a lot to explain but at least that's the
short version right he was he almost
lost our he was our first lawyer when
that happened
and his take was um you should take this
on it's really easy right yes he said
don't yeah it's an easy dub
um and then when he was all like dude
all the other activists uh organizations
are going to want to get on this like
ACLU all these people they're going to
back us up and azer he's just some like
uh meme attorney on Reddit yeah at the
time the video game attorney was that
yeah
and then when the when I got sued by
Matt Haas
and then we raised a bunch of money he
had this genius idea to start a
non-profit and donate the money there
the fupa yeah and also so that was one
thing the other thing was um
that their legal arguments were
absolutely insane instead of attacking
the Merit
of fair use their first attempt was to
dismiss it based on a technicality of
the of the uh patent yeah or the
copyright which makes no sense because
they could have resolved it and settled
it immediately makes no [__] sense
um and it was so bad that when we
went to our next Attorney because we're
like these guys are going to ruin our
life he the other attorneys were like I
genuinely want to file like a
malpractice against them like this is
insane
uh that didn't happen it wasn't worth it
but um what did happen was
so the money that was donated to the
non-profit
you can't donate to a non-profit and
then spend it on yourself it's illegal
right so we got this and we did
everything with them advising us what to
do
right yeah you were giving bad advice
yeah like I don't know how much context
to give people but basically Philly D
started a fund and GoFundMe to help us
with this lawsuit overnight it became
like there's 80 000 in it and then like
by the next day there was like 180 000
in it it was like 150 after the 450 and
I did not plan to talk about this so I
hope I'm not getting things wrong oh
correct this is just based on my shitty
memory yeah but so the when we saw so
much money we were like well we don't
want to take it all we want to do
something with this we want to help
other people he told us that's way more
money than you'll ever need oh yes
that's so we're like okay great you also
said that so he's like let's put it in
listen to this scheme this guy puts
together he goes let's put it in a
non-profit and then you can just pay me
to represent other people you and other
people yeah
and so we did that and then the attorney
that made it for us
realized he's like wait you're doing
this to pay for your own lawsuit and
then he got freaked out he's like I
can't be involved in this this is fraud
he said it's Friday he freaked out the
guy the lawyer he hired to do it because
he didn't give him the facts either
and so when we moved to change attorneys
and got a new and we put the money in
that account in the non-profit account
we couldn't touch it for like years
because it was illegal yeah when we
switched lawyers they're like you cannot
touch this right now this is fraud damn
and so the money that people donate to
us we couldn't use
and so um
when we got a new accountant they were
able to like Lobby and explain to the
Attorney General of New York State what
happened and we're able to dissolve the
non-profit and get the money back after
a couple of years also also we did
announce this whole like thing that they
were this lawyers will be helping the
community yeah and then the the guys
couldn't handle it like Ryan and his
other guy well we started paying out of
pocket because we couldn't use that
money that too but they were like not
really doing it too well they were
incompetent they were so incompetent
straight up like just
but that's my I didn't know anything at
the time yeah I just went some this guy
seemed like he whatever I got I got in
my opinion
taken for a ride but you got an
expensive lesson is what you got yes I'm
a lot smarter now about things but um
another reason why I'm pissed at him is
because this whole fupa fund
right that turned into the whole thing
with keemstar and you were harangued
about it for years yeah of people
accusing me of stealing the money and
stuff was all literally a consequence of
all this [__] I couldn't use the
money yeah when I tried to use my own
out-of-pocket money they weren't able to
really do it and it was costing us a
fortune to be honest it wasn't feasible
at the time we didn't have a lot of
money no and then also he said it wasn't
going to cost a lot of money so I
pledged all this money to help and then
we realized as we were racking up like a
hundred thousand dollars in bills and
couldn't touch that money right that we
were going to need that money for
ourselves yeah so that that's so Ryan
Morrison is just wow he is a [__]
real piece of [__] but maybe he's
changed
you just got paid though it sounds like
he's not a shitty lawyer but again
as an agent maybe he found his calling
now
uh
uh sure it happened
that's when we left ultimately when we
ultimately decided to leave they were
the ones that were like yes take this
lawsuit on an easy win then they they
decided at the end to advise us to pay
him multiple they said you should settle
this you should settle him like uh a few
tens of thousands of dollars I don't
remember the exactly I won't say the
exact amount because I don't remember
but it was a lot and that was the point
where I was like you guys are scam
artists and we are living the legend of
your opinion in my opinion in my opinion
that's what I said I
yeah it's what you use my thoughts and
prayers yeah because they were like once
their original motion to dismiss it on a
technicality would make no sense at all
got dismissed they're like
we gotta throw in the towel
I mean morons and then when we got to
our new attorney who's amazing
he fi we started taking it on like
legitimately he filed a motion to uh for
summary judgment
and then a motion for dismissal which it
got granted on the motion dismissal on
the merits of
it being fair use yes fair use
yeah it was a horrible time it was the
worst time of our life honestly it was
so stressful we couldn't talk about
anything it was just terrible and it was
just the two of us dealing with lawyers
on this side lawyers on this side yeah
um we were moving cross-country from New
York to L.A it was like the worst time
yeah that was a hard that was one of the
worst times man dealing with that and
then all these [__] pieces of [__]
like keemstar and all of his buddies
yeah coming out and being like Ethan's
scamming people and stealing money
that was tough man mudahar took it back
he did God bless moodle I don't want to
put it he's the only one in his team he
took it back he's the only one yep no I
like Moodle all right yeah it wasn't
just them that was the one that made me
snap finally right yeah ironically
but okay Brian Morrison there he is
shaking it up
this is a more than professional athlete
and mega Star Mr Morrison said it breaks
my heart to even hear that also the
problem is because
he used us so much to promote him he was
the OG if there ever was a clout Goblin
and if I can ever say that about anyone
it's Mr Ryan Morrison
because when we made all these videos
about the Matt Haas lawsuit at the time
it was always like Mr and my Ryan
Morrison is doing so much for us and
he's awesome and all this [__]
and then we slowly realized like um
I really regret even recommending him to
people but it worked out for xqc
you know I I just realized we reacted to
his him being his lawyer way back
because yeah you see it was about to sue
uh the Olympics I think
and we realized video game attorney was
his lawyer yeah what happened you guys
remember that yeah I remember that I
totally forgot about it I don't remember
but um uh but I do his name has come up
a few times and I'm always like oh my
God yo this guy looks like him but it's
not him that's unfortunate this is him
and then here's another Ryan Morrison
that looks kind of similar
don't you think
yeah this is him I see it does Ryan
Morrison look like Ryan morrison.com
oh good yeah who which is who's who
but he's done well for himself good
yeah the firm that they put together him
and his buddy uh who was apparently this
amazing litigator I guess they broke up
not surprisingly surprised and then he
did he started his own thing
awesome so that was a weird change
good for xqc 100 million [__] dollars
um
before we move on just to uh address all
the people asking why the angle is like
this it's not because we like it it's
because we're having some issues with
our camera this is the only one that
works on this side so we made it real
wide so you can see everybody that is a
silly goofy angle I'll go wide with you
guys in solidarity one sec go wide baby
go wide cam let's go oh my God
[Applause]
I felt it power to the people you're the
man power to the people I feel like it
looks like a sitcom
right it does
[Laughter]
like wearing a Megazord
today this might be a super fun shot to
see all of our reactions together that's
true
it's true oh he used to write me um
Ryan used to write me messages and [__]
like or you know I I don't remember if
I'm recalling this exactly yeah let's
not get sued today yeah I'm not going to
say anything that I can't recall exactly
but shout out to xqc huh congrats I mean
at the end of the day who can blame the
guy for taking a hundred million dollar
deal it's hard for two years cheers my
dude even if he probably does need to
Cheers my dude cheers my dude
even if he probably is gonna have to
gamble like a hundred hours a month or
something insane yeah at stake.com
exclusively I mean maybe I guess we'll
see we'll see here's the thing like
because it's similar to like you know
mixer was Microsoft's streaming platform
and they tried the same strategy of uh
poaching a bunch of the top talent from
twitch right yeah and like people's like
dissatisfaction with twitch is nothing
new like I can't remember a time when
everybody wasn't just always mad at
twitch for whatever yeah um
but something does feel a little
different about it this time to me
um I mean first of all they have this
crazy amount of crypto money I I don't
think anybody billions of dollars 100
million deal they have could be wrong
but in my opinion you're doing anything
that big they have billions of dollars
in crypto just sitting there remember
they got Drake too
oh yeah how much they pay Drake oh my
God this time right right and so they
they have yeah I just looked it up they
paid ninja who I think was the biggest
deal that mixer did between 20 and 30
million so we're talking way more than
that yeah they have infinite money yeah
I don't think they have any
they're like the Saudi [__] uh wealth
fund or whatever yeah exactly and yeah
the uh
I don't know it it seems like kick is
starting up right at a time when twitch
really is fumbling pretty [__] hard
and like that kind of scenario is the
times that like big social platforms
transition you know what I mean kind of
seeing something similar on Reddit with
how badly they're handling all of this
like IPO stuff and everybody getting mad
at them
but um well you know I think it's sad if
kick does end up becoming a thing
because
they're not good people in my opinion
and uh that platform is not going to be
used unlike Amazon
I'm I'm so salty that they're not on the
same level but it is funny I mean listen
Amazon obviously is a giant corporate
[__] unfeeling uh yeah I mean Amazon
capitalist yeah at least you know
they're that's kind of part there's
something to the business model other
than gambling right you know supposedly
Drake is making a 100 million a year as
well oh 100 million per year so wow that
can't even be worth it he streams to
like two four thousand people like
people don't even care about his [__]
well his Instagram posts are crazy yeah
the Instagram posts plus like sometimes
I feel like it just makes it legitimate
to people that a celebrity is usually oh
for sure yeah for sure
I'm so mad at YouTubers and stepping up
to the they could be the [__] juice
from Augustus in the streaming business
I wish someone would [__] pay me I'm
pretty popular live show yeah make a
[__] home page make it like a front
page live like for all the live
streamers boom [__] twitch make a
better shot too their AI is a lot worse
on YouTube as well for streaming twitch
is a lot better
Ludwig has called out uh YouTube for the
same thing YouTube's app can't even stay
open so they can't yeah exactly and
they're like you're lying to me when I
send it to them
nobody's ever offered me money like that
where's my [__] offers
didn't a steak offer you in a tweet like
messing around oh I don't remember
send me an offer steak let's see what we
can talk about 100 million
I'll jump ship for 100 million [__] it
I'll come on next week and be like
listen guys I wanna I wanna mention my
fantastic spark Partners over at
stake.com I'm gonna be doing my first
gambling stream here
you guys like watching
who's ready to play Salon special guests
it is so fun it's so exciting Drake's
gonna be joining us a little bit later
in front of me's new co-host Drake the
CEO is going to be calling in later to
talk about these great uh uh generous
initiative he has going on all kinds of
beautiful Charities he's a great great
guy
he's on charity
dick.com
can you imagine
that'd be awesome
where's my 100 million stake you [__]
build that goddamn bag up
right now yo I'm happy to introduce my
favorite slot coming out this month
talking about uh we're releasing our own
slot the uh
what's our boy's name the door repair
flashlight guy we're releasing our own
Malik Fleshlight slot machine featuring
all of our favorite flesh-like
characters talking about the Beauty and
the Beast the Thomas the Tank the train
all of them you can put the coin in
insert your dick insert the coin hit the
jackpot
thank you
yeah
foreign
actually I'm happy to announce my
collaboration with train wreck and Aiden
Ross we're gonna be doing a co-gabling
stream with these two great guys that I
can't say anything I only have nice
things to say about
big dubs for my best friend's train
wreck and Aiden Ross nice to see you
guys how you guys doing today
such a treasure to be here with you guys
you guys are good dude
be playing some fortnite with uh Kanye
absolutely okay guys ready on three
let's all do our first spin together one
two three spin
steak.com
jackpot I just need a jack full of my
first pin you guys
this dollars that are crazy these this
this casino just pays out
[Laughter]
times man
love it
so anyway
cheers my dude cheers my dudes I'm gonna
go potty that coffee hit me different
love ya no homo
in a good way it's just so sugary I
think I dying I want a bad way yeah in a
bad way oh
okay we'll we'll get you a new flavor
next time no just keep me out
to figure it out it's all regret every
time no but I see your face every time
you're like
the idea
[Music]
I'm souring on it no me and Bob are just
not meant to be yeah
you can't give up on them have you tried
the classic brown sugar it's so [__]
sweet dude no but it's just wrong I'm on
a diet I can't be slurping down [__]
100 grams of sugar which is probably
what's in those things we yeah it is
good check the check the sugar I don't
wanna I wanna okay I want for you I will
no what'd you say their classic flavor
is love
uh brown sugar check the brown sugar
calories on a large with Boba chocolate
not calories sugar grams of sugar yeah
they're all different flavors and
different flavors
that is very sweet and it's creamy and
the Boba is like pure sugar I mean I'm
on a diet man my body doesn't know what
to do when I eat that much sugar these
days
[__]
I'm pre-diabetic according to my latest
uh
blood work
barely
although I I won't be there for long I
think who isn't applauding that
okay well pre-diabetic I mean like
before diabetic it's not a good thing
it's not a good thing at all
but Dan did you think it was too late no
I just said he's not diabetic yeah it's
good news I was right on the edge of
being pre-diabetic but I'm sure
it's going to go down you all want him
to be diabetic what was your glucose
okay my glucose yeah I can check I have
to say it's shocking sad that I had to
look up the sweetest
um Boba drink to give you this answer to
um brown sugar milk tea Boba has 19
grams of sugar that's not that's
reasonable I feel like that's a lie
though there's no [__] chance that's
true I feel it
the 19 is not a lot for a drink like
that dude the the Thai tea smoothie the
large one that has 62 grams
hey you must they must have fudged you
with the serving size you know I think
I'm out too I liked my first Sip and
then I was like this is too sweet I
can't a regular is 19 large 25. dude
that's not 62 though but that's still a
law that that I feel like they're lying
speaking of that though do we want to
order food
I could I could my body's ravaged I'm
working on it right now if you guys want
to send orders to what are we getting I
don't know some Za
but some of the what now
can I get Zao with the Brock
it's actually very nutritious yeah it's
true I'm trying to find let's see
cookies and cream shake that sounds
healthy that's what I got that oh you
did good 83 grams of sugar bro what if
you get extra Oreo oh I'm sure that's
probably more cookies for you 83 600
calories
that's my breakfast at lunch right there
breakfast lunch and dinner 83 calories
I'm just or 83 grams of sugar I mean my
God
Olivia what are you doing to me yo we
need to stop that's what's happening
oh my God I think that maybe
I'm never gonna have Boba again Boba
it's nice but it's poisonous
every time I drink Boba I feel horrible
thank you I feel like [__]
today because I thought about that I
almost didn't get it today but I was
like I'm gonna regret when everybody has
it Olivia cursed me I wanted to be nice
to get you up at the moments the like
the bobas come in yeah it is really
exciting when we know it's coming yeah
100 I'm happy we're on the same page I
Want A visual representation we need to
find something else
oh we can invest in like smoothies do
you want to start doing that we could
start thinking about something healthy
like with some spinach in it absolutely
yeah maybe some boba too
let me see if there's like a website
where I can do 83 grams of sugar
hold on why is no one talking about like
fake sugar Boba is that a thing I think
it tastes like [__] because it's so
sweet I don't know is it a thing I'm
sure I'm sure there well I don't know
cam sent a good video you just gotta
double that yeah double that okay
so this is 42 grams yep so imagine two
of these straight to the Dome if you
ever wanna
realize how much sugar there is in a can
of pop here's 42 grams of sugar that's
nothing
[Music]
how much sugar no way
that's a whole mountain of sugar Mound
is whoa that's crazy this is like a
really really grams double that that's
crazy but even looked like the double
that
Boba is kind of like dark arts because
yeah it's always full it's oh there's a
line all people are slurping it down and
we're talking about 80 grams of sugar to
the Dome yeah I'm telling you this might
be like a you might be getting a red
pill a little though Boba red pilled
this might be like a terrorist act I
don't know because like the terrorists
got smart after 9 11. they might be on
Boba you think they went they went
operation Boba yeah yeah kill them with
the sweet poison you know I mean they
got me
I think Isis might own boba
Al-Qaeda is behind Boba for sure
Osama bin boba
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm telling you when they when they
searched his compound they found all
kinds of notes about boba in there
yeah so are we are we good on the food
order
I cannot find a place that has broccoli
on Pizza seriously I see that everywhere
the Brock oh
yeah you want to see I'll pull up my
blood work Zach I'll tell you my
do you know about glucose levels like
you know what it means I do yes my good
friend is a type 2 diabetic so that's
the one you become
I think that's the it's type one or type
two I forget think type one's the one
you're born with right yeah he was born
with it so I I don't know I I'm just I'm
guessing I don't know are you guys want
to know about my lab work
okay
she was doing now
you know this link I sent I was
wondering what fresh and fit we're
talking about with their new video but
now it makes sense it was about Boba
their new video is called exposing 911
part two oh yeah that's awesome man
they know that it has to be what it's
about I mean it's been like 20 years are
they making an explosion 911 it's 2023
you guys why have they been sitting on
this they found the they found the the
Boba dogs what do they know what are we
doing
so actually I I have some weird uh blood
work that's stressed me out this morning
I thought I had cancer for sure I'm not
gonna lie this morning what happened
this morning I got some because I did a
bunch I had weird blood uh
values when I did my I just did the
whole blood work to test my cholesterol
and stuff was fine
but then they my white blood
cells and platelet clowns were high
so my doctor was like it's probably it's
probably nothing but I can send you to a
hematologist I was like
what'd you say
I said I okay I thought you're yelling
at me no I said I like oil
it's scary randomly said hey
well that wasn't super weird but then I
went to the hematologist and we did a
whole bunch of tests
that was you know earlier this week
and they started coming in and so like
here's one that try try try Grizzle or
try no no try tryptase
try it try try taste tricycle taste a
lot of this stuff has to do with like
leukemia
my tripe taste is elevated and then I
Google that and it's like you either
have a lupus or leukemia
Jesus what and then I go back and I say
okay and then I got another one today
hold on let me go back
my uh Anna titer
and a tighter this is um also like
leukemia and lupus and [__] my levels
are [__] insane and the note says
homogeneous and speckled exclamation
whoever did the blood test put an
exclamation on my [__] diagnosis
that's so [__] mean what well I'll
I'll tell you just so you don't get
worried okay I wrote the doctor this
morning I was like I'm super stressed
out like what's what's going on with
these and he just wrote me back yeah and
it makes me feel a little bit and
actually this morning I had a
conversation with Chad gbt that made me
feel a little better too oh boy
conversation oh boy I did I said you
know doctors doesn't seem like good
results on the try taste test I'm
stressing about it and he said it's not
a very high elevation I want to not be
stressed about it still waiting for the
molecular studies
so
and chat gbt was like it could be uh
chat gbt was like it's probably not
leukemia
oh good it could be lupus but I don't
have enough and the thing is really bad
too
I mean it's not like deadly usually it's
an autoimmune disease you can like treat
it okay but the weird thing is I don't
have any symptoms like my lymph nodes
aren't swollen yeah what would be the
symptoms of lupus
I see inflammation of the face that's
not familiar at all it's a little it's I
told the doctor about that yeah that I
was having rashes I don't even know what
the [__] lupus is lupus symptoms I
wasn't really I'll take lupus over
[__] uh cancer
lupus symptoms includes um muscle and
joint pain no fever no rashes sometimes
they get on my face but it's been gone
for a while chest pain no hair loss I
mean look at me
sun or light sensitivity no kidney
problems mouth sores prolonged or
extreme fatigue anemia I don't have
anemia in the blood test memory problems
oh
now my memory is fine blood clotting eye
disease of me I mean my I feel like my
long-term memory is good my short-term
memory sometimes a lot on the opposite I
feel like my short-term memory is good
together we're [__] A Perfect Memory
power couple so the lupus doesn't make
sense but then if you go to leukemia
great so what does it mean so I don't I
don't [__] know it's been stressing
me out to be honest with you and this
morning I wasn't think thinking about it
this much but then I got these test
results
I'm like oh I'm [__] dying I thought
for sure I was like I have to get a bone
marrow
test I need to [__]
uh
uh I have I have leukemia
yeah yeah so then here's symptoms of
leukemia fever or chills no persistent
fatigue weakness I mean I get fatigued
but I always figure because I'm fat but
that alone I don't think frequent or
severe infections no
losing weight without trying no I'm
trying very hard and when I'm not I'm
getting fat it's one lymph nodes my
lymph nodes are not swollen the doctor
just checked me a couple days ago
enlarged liver or spleen is what what'd
you say
so you got tight little lymph nodes yeah
[__] tight little lymph nodes the
doctor did send me to get a um
ultrasound on my organs but that's not
coming up for a while but it says uh
enlarge the first plane easy bleeding or
bruising no reoccurring nosebleeds no
tiny red spots on your skin no except
for sweating especially at night no bone
pain or tenderness no I have no symptoms
wow because so chat TBD is like because
you have no symptoms like leukemia and
lupus usually are accompanied with
symptoms then it's hard for me so what
could it be that's crazy
because at first it was like my blood
platelets were super high and my white
blood cells were super high and that
means one of those not super high I
guess but it was above the normal
and my original general doctor was like
it could be that you just have high
values on that and it's fine I went to
the hematology high value male exactly
exactly it's just a high value mantle
it's no big deal
good thing and then um well when I got
really stressed when I got these other
test results and I was like oh [__]
there's other [__] going on here
like let me read you some of the other
ones I got
um
apparently I have here CBC and auto
differential so you can see my platelets
are pretty high 530
it's like uh the thickness of your blood
or something okay some kind of thing
about your blood and then a certain type
of what white blood cell is just a
little bit High just a little bit over
the norm which is the basso fill
so that's not too troubling but then I
get down to the A and A this one was
normal
get down to the tri-spate this one
stressed me out
because it's almost double the normal
range
then I saw
uh I don't know what IG is that one's
normal
erythora popatine that one's normal
hopefully the doctors are listening the
Anna tighter one [__] me up
it says their normal value is between 1
to 40 and 1 to 80 minus one to three
twenty
and then again he wrote
the guy who did this here I'll send this
to you so people can see how freaked out
it made me
the lab that did this they wrote an
exclamation in red after this show look
at this
here pull this up Dan Jesus
why do they even send you this to you
not to your doctor they do but they they
send it to both they do that here and
then you can um you can see it for
yourself and then you can also wait to
hear what the doctor says right
makes sense I guess they send you the
results and then the doctor contacts you
when they get everything in
yeah but pull that up Dan
that one freaked me the [__] out dude
look at this
look at this [__] annotator
it's homogeneous and speckled
maybe it's a good thing yeah
I doubt
maybe it's click bait
so that's basically it I was going to
have you ask your brother if I'm dying
Lena
but the doctor already got back to me do
you want me to share your results with
him yeah yeah tell your brother okay
he's officially a resident now so in
California
like practicing doctor what does
resident mean so it's after you graduate
and then then you do residency for a few
years and then you're officially well I
mean he's he's a doctor now yeah yeah
and he stick a finger for a few years
but did he move here you guys say yeah
he just moved here too
can you stick a finger in the ass
congrats so I guess that's kind of nice
for you yeah that's exciting good for
him yeah all right well tell him to drop
everything because I'm dying
yeah so tell him this here you can tell
him this my sister is also being a
doctor in San Fran they should be your
sister's adopted she's in med school
right now oh yeah you guys are so
amazing you have doctors in your family
that I feel like that's cool for your
whole family
so tell him here pull up that one uh Dan
tell him my ass is speckled and
homogeneous
his ass is sorry you're a genius yeah so
I tell them my um oh got that okay my
Anna tighter is one to three twenty
mm-hmm and then in all caps with the
exclamation homogeneous and speckled
gotcha I'm gonna share all of this with
him right now actually maybe he's
available to get back to me yeah and
then the other one was I can't handle
the idea of anything well I thought I
was I thought for sure I had leukemia
this morning
I'm glad at least the doctor sent me
a comforting message and it met it does
mirror what uh chat GPT did tell me as
well so did he give you a reasoning why
or not yet he says he's he says it's not
a very high elevation I would not be
stressed about it
still waiting for the molecular study so
I guess there's more test results he's
still waiting on your does your mom have
autoimmune problems yeah she does she
has colitis is it genetic autoimmune
disease I'm sure it is but I don't have
I don't know I don't have Colitis
it's a different one but he did test me
for autoimmune autoimmune disease and I
don't know if it's one of these values
or something else that's coming back
because the other tests were normal
but the good news is my cholesterol is
fine
if I don't die of cancer before uh
I have a heart attack
that would suck
yeah because you'll probably have to go
back to Sweden love if I die yeah [__]
that
don't do that you know
your Visa probably gets canceled if I
die
well
yeah maybe I don't know about that
I'm sorry though dude I know that's a
very scary
um well actually I feel a lot better
since I got that mess from the doctor
but that's good
yeah
liver enzymes what did you say I
remember being [__] terrified but I
went back and it was fine completely
fine just the first test I don't know
why I said they were so elevated
after the fight no no this was years ago
this was like 2013
yeah I just I was doing routine blood
work and my liver enzymes were super
high and I was freaking out I was
thinking that I was I was looking it up
things went down just I went back and
it's fine something huh
I don't know I forget why they said that
it was
maybe just a misread or something not a
misread but uh why they were so high so
the weird thing about this is that I did
a blood test a year ago yeah and my
platelets and white blood cells were
elevated back then too so it's been a
year oh
they these doctors can see your last
yeah blood test and last time nobody
said anything to you about it because I
don't remember talking about this I
guess not but I also remember right
before we left Israel I did a blood
checkup
and I might be misremembering but I
remember the doctor saying that my white
blood count was high and she wanted to
do a follow-up on it and then I we left
like a few days later I never stepped on
it so I don't know what the [__]
Ethan is being a little bit
hypochondriac are you [__] kidding
dude
no this isn't hypochondriac stop it
what was this how many years ago were
you talking about that you uh I don't
know for sure but that would have been
like seven years ago
but I know for sure a year ago I had
high blood uh white blood cells and
platelets
if I die play chestnuts at my funeral
you got it man we'll get a Nook for it
play me chestnuts right now dude you got
it one thing
[Music]
I feel like I hate having too much
information it's like he's like here's
all right well done oh my God
how cooked can you be
if I am dying this guy is flame broiled
he is done
oh man he just did a cover of My Heart
Will Go On it's so beautiful
oh yeah
well the good news is if I do have
cancer because I was not I'm not
symptomatic at all so if I do we caught
it I guess
early as earlier than I would have if I
started having symptoms you know what I
mean absolutely but I don't I think this
whole this idea of cancer seems unlikely
based on what chapter BT told me and uh
the doctor told me not to worry so I'm
trusting him on that one
but if you look up all the ones that I'm
abnormal for it all is like you have
leukemia or lupus
I'll take lupus any day bro hit me with
that lupus
why um oh but then Luke I hear what
you're saying obviously because I think
lupus is pretty bad too yeah no one is
cancer I wouldn't hope that you had
lupus either well if you had to make me
choose yeah if I didn't right no I get
what you're saying like I'll take lupus
every day
Selena has lupus she does Selena Gomez
right and she's a queen yeah she's a
queen she's manager number one on
Instagram maybe I'll get more followers
yeah maybe lupus will get you the number
two
lupus uh lupus Legends you and Selena
yeah you could be like spokespeople for
Lupus you could start attending events
with her
all the alphas are plotting on my desk
number two on Instagram
ela's so ugly they're gonna start
hitting you up in the DMS for sure
Jesus well especially since you're
getting divorced
can't divorce me now that'd be [__] up
oh that'd be so [__] up
now to be like the only reason Ela is
not divorcing either because he's he's
dying
she for sure would have left them by now
well please keep us posted dear Jesus
oh someone that it also suggested
schurgen syndrome the Chachi BT
suggested that I don't know what the
[__] that is what is that uh I don't
think it's as bad as the other option so
I take a little bit of a shrogan
syndrome
um but the other thing about lupus is
that according to Chad gbt that would
lower my platelet count and my platelet
count is going up
um uh shrogan's syndrome is a sort of
your immune system identified by two
most common symptoms dry eyes and dry
mouth I don't really have those no
cheers my dude and it's accompanied by
rheumatoid arthritis and lupus
Schrodinger syndrome huh try eyes dry
mouth dry skin tiredness I mean I'm
tired vaginal dryness love ya
foreign
I don't know if that one applies muscle
or joint pain no swelling that's the
weird thing I don't have any [__]
symptoms
what's so funny dude I'm dying why are
you laughing
I literally told you I have leukemia and
you're laughing play chestnuts I'm not
laughing at that even I promise you
maybe you're just so awful that you have
more blood coming you know
that's what I'm saying you have all
these yeah
[Music]
foreign
this one's dedicated to cutie Cinderella
who ultimately
gets to have her moment when I die due
to the sound of chestnuts
[Music]
you know if I did die the funeral will
be off the chains like this
stop it I'm not talking about your
funeral
be off the [__] chains dude
[Music]
oh God my boyfriend passed away from
lupus within a year of being diagnosed
Sarah don't say that um blocker
oh
I'm sorry to hear that mute her please
sorry to hear that what the hell I'm
sorry Sarah I didn't know it was that
serious yeah I'm telling you it's
serious because well when I read about
lupus uh
it said like I guess like 90 of people
survived which is not I know great but
it's not cancer it's not cancer yeah and
it's treatable
it says people who get it who get it
treated can live a normal like lifespan
um
I still don't know what the [__] lupus
is let's watch this video
John Hopkins
a video for Ethan Clark I gotta know
what lupus is I don't know what the [__]
it is this won't get claimed John
Hopkins you're coming after me for
learning about lupus I'm trying to
educate myself I've got lupus and you're
coming and claiming my videos yeah how
dare they
systemic lupus is uh chronic
inflammatory disease uh it's an
autoimmune disease so basically the
immune system starts
oh this guy's an assistant professor he
is not a surgeon can we get some
credentials please I guess he's an MD
he's an empty okay chill I I don't care
I'm not trying to I'm trying to talk
about my blood work
somebody's own body is foreign and
starts attacking them
it doesn't have any cure so it generally
is lifelong it mostly affects women of
reproductive age
it's most common in African Americans
followed by Hispanics Asians and
caucasians in the United States so I'm
pretty good occurred later in life but
the classic Dogma is that it's females
of reproductive age that's not sometimes
more common my vagina is not dry either
it's
I've got a nice moist vagina down here
[Music]
oh
it can have varied presentations since
SLE can attack any part of the body
everybody can present in a different
pattern what they go through what kind
of books they have something that's the
honest severe disease
mostly with rashes and Joints
occasionally you can tell what kind of
Lupus they will have based on their
serological profiles and some is anybody
listening to the videos
but in general it is a chronic disease
that can Flare from time to time so
patients can do very well there is some
super chats while you watch this
on average
here's one from chat and you're in good
show recommendations
I did see a lot of people saying I don't
know what I'll do without the show
well listen I'm as much as I'm worried
about you guys not having the podcast
and that is important to me
it's probably a good highlight no I like
that's nice that's a nice car somebody
donated uh the devil actually donated
twenty dollars oh [__] what did he said
and said have you tried turning yourself
off and on again
that's actually good advice
works with computers a lot yeah can you
play chestnuts again please
actually I'm glad I'm also a
hypochondriac bro trust me this isn't
this isn't that
you hear about those tri-tight levels
where the [__] my tri-tight levels are
crazy
I'm glad I talked about it because I've
been stressing hard distance this
morning yeah I didn't even know
I was trying to get here early and I was
on Pace
and then I started seeing these lab
results come in
and then I was like doing research and
then I ran downstairs to talk to chat
gbt
you guys laughed but that [__] robot
knows what it's talking about and Jeep
chat DBT did make me feel better but if
you want to forward the results
I could ask
[Laughter]
[Music]
what'd you say if you want to forward
the results I could ask two other
doctors it's up to you it'll probably be
quicker
how do I do that I don't even know how
to do that because there's like a ton of
them screenshot I'll look after the show
if you want I can
yeah
I mean your doctors are looking he's
he's good I think he seems like a good
dog I mean he he's a hemo
oh yeah no I'm just saying if you wanted
more info sooner thanks bro yeah
I want three doctors all together
telling me I'm dying
well the devil actually donated another
20 and said it's not your time Ethan but
we'll welcome you with open arms when
you join us oh great [__] make a wish
just donated 50.
I'm not a Make-a-Wish okay
thank you I don't need your Make-a-Wish
charity
here I met here here's my here's my wish
that I don't have cancer can you make
that come true
no but we can get you Spider-Man
and at the Chuck E Cheese party
you like Chuck E cheese are we talking
Toby McGuire or Hollywood Boulevard
Spidey can we get uh the rock maybe to
play video games with me at Chuck E
cheese
oh another 50 and another what this is
of course our uh Euler this is members
go up he renamed himself make a wish to
be totally fair though my whole life has
been kind of a Make-A-Wish
I mean in the sense that
all his dreams have come true and also
just from pity and uh basically had from
a place of fitting right yeah yeah let's
give him a good let's just give him a
good way out
um so that's what I'll update you guys
but yeah not good kind of stressful I'm
sorry dude
thanks bro
so either you want to play dress up
well we were talking about just for
early things did we order food what do
we get
we got that saw we did yeah but I
couldn't find any with broccoli but I
did get your the other combo you really
like mine yeah oh what's up
what did I get
I got four pizzas oh I got a veggie a
white pizza a kale and sausage pizza and
um the combo the OG are you gonna bring
some of that home to eat in bed yes
absolutely of course she is everybody
bring pizza are you kidding I want
pictures of everyone eating in bed later
oh my God I'm not gonna do that Daddy
would love on Dan yeah well let's bring
pizza home for Teddy by the way did you
guys use the stain-free sheets that we
got in no they're sitting uh
office good there's no stains it's fine
uh
90 if you guys are ready or are you
saying we're still talking about purple
that was 90 minutes I guess let's just
do the ELO one that sounds more fun and
if we have more time
we can finish up on the Pearly ship I
mean there's just a little bit more
about her coping on Twitter but right
maybe one of the outfits you could wear
if like a sad occasion comes up or
something like that mm-hmm right like a
funeral
just Jesus
uh so we could we'll do this segment
because it's fun and then we'll do some
tater juice
but I wanted to talk about the bow back
sleep did you hear about this no so
black that got leaked and it's in we can
do that it is so [__] funny and so
bad we were I was joking this is like
the worst all exposed maybe of all time
I'm down to do that first okay
let's skip ahead to the Boby Lake
um
I thought I talked a little bit about it
I do want to I want to make one thing
clear for the sake of Boby yes we did
invite him on the show okay
or to the live show because we thought
it'd be funny if he's in the audience
he's like uh stop laughing at Sonic or
whatever that would have been amazing
and then he was like I don't he said the
man has a lot of respect for himself he
says I don't want to be a human
uh jukebox so I'll pass and and and fair
to him frankly I was like wow I was like
cool good good for you bro I mean I did
more self-respect than that I wasn't
planning on bringing him out there to
make fun of him I thought it'd be like a
fun mutual thing but yeah but if that's
how he perceives it then that's right
then that's gonna be like you were you
wanted to hear like a q a from the
audience and then and then he would yell
for you to talk about the allegations
yeah or something yeah that would have
been and then he would be an auditorium
full of people applauding for him they
would have he would have been Rockstar
it would have been so awesome but I
would have loved on Bobby that's what it
is the thing is people he's allowed to
feel about it however he feels you know
it's fine when people join the family
it's all love that's right
delayed until they're all Fleek because
he was tripping I guess he was uh
so I want to make that clear for his
sake because he was I guess angry that I
implied that we said no to him not he
said no to us
watch it and like I you didn't unless
you you may have looped back to it later
but like when we were talking about it
it
I understood how he interpreted that way
but you didn't actually say that that's
what like we didn't say it this came out
and now we're canceling him or anything
like that so the reason I just wanted to
clarify it is because before I show him
saying this insane [__] on his all I
just want to make it clear okay and we
offered the invite before the we saw the
office before this yeah but he said no
to us he rejected us okay that DM wasn't
even the DM that he shared was my DM
that was me and him talking not Ethan he
cropped out the names
he had an idea I had an idea it's my
fault no it's not your fault
yeah I thought it was a good idea
no it was a good idea yeah
I love the initiative you take on on
stuff like that okay
uh so Bobby said at this point H3 pays
more attention to what I do than I pay
attention to him what the [__]
come on Bobby
oh blacks he says uh I barely talk about
him anymore but if I do anything that
could be seen as bad he pounces on it I
mean okay so
that's what you do bro that's your whole
career that's the game exactly that's
the game Bobby that's the game Bobby
he says I legit have to walk on
eggshells during my 20 to 50 viewer
streams because I know if I slip up I'll
get posted to H3 subreddit and covered
by Ethan so you know how it feels to be
one of the people you obsessively talk
about I don't care though I don't think
of I mean yeah that's how the internet
works bro
yes that just means that like you're
important enough on the internet
irrelevant yeah it means you're relevant
that's just anybody
if you're live you have to think about
that yeah just don't you know I'm live
all the time yeah I do this [__] I have
to think about that yeah everybody does
he's like bro I can't even say the
n-word without a game posted this summer
a huge reason why I make my stream odds
members always because of that okay I
mean [__] what do you want for me look
forward to him lying more Friday when he
covers my all account where I'm totally
not playing a character and everything I
say is real okay listen
as I go through the all let's just
remember bobox is playing a character
throbbing horse [__]
right the uh example is throbbing horse
[__] and I see that the little subtitle
is mine's bigger so so just remember
this isn't both this is boby's all but
it's a character it's a character yeah
I'll be I'm just being as real as I can
we're an acting class okay everything he
says on it is real which he means
everything I say is just a joke so it's
just a joke and he's threat this is
throbbing horse [__]
it's a prank bro so here's some of the
awesome tweets how was it revealed that
it's his alt how it always is he was
like streaming and then clicked his
Twitter and then they saw the name and
icon and then they find it on Twitter
and they're like oh [__] this is epic so
he wrote in 2019 trans women aren't real
women but I'd still [__] the [__] out of
them
that's just him playing a character wait
wait I want to point something out this
is the tweets that he included yeah this
is oh he tweeted this out right right so
he's giving these as the example so keep
that in mind because the tame ones
you'll notice that these are all from
2019. okay there's new ones newer ones
okay that's what I'm trying to say okay
so yeah these ones are from 2019 so it's
a little bit dated I guess
um we've come up we've come a bit of
ways since 2019
uh but he's still [__] them right that's
in a sense
I'm not sure what that is
just a character it's a joke yeah okay
he said Trump Liberals are restarted
again these are the ones he posted I'd
rather be enslaved to some hot ass babe
rather than a bloody old man who gets
nailed to the cross like a cuck I don't
know what the [__] that means maybe talk
about Jesus
take this huge l oh thank you Lena
get on gab should have put whatever so
let's get to the good so these are the
good ones right okay so these are recent
now well this is more this is more more
and by the way this was just on Friday
because I was like yo we saw Bobby's oh
it's awesome that's all I said I was
like we don't have time to get to it and
then he had a meltdown on Wednesday yeah
you said yeah on Wednesday he posted a
clip of it he says uh
they invited me on the live to be human
soundboard but changed his mind after my
races all got leaked dude I literally
rejected the invite last Thursday four
hours after it was sent why are you
lying and saying it's because of the alt
correct
you rejected us it had nothing to do
with the all you that's all you bro
like you you can have that W you you
rejected us man
and it it hurt
[Applause]
we're gonna miss you at the live show we
really will can't always get what you
want Ethan no like not having cancer
whoa
what the [__] what is this whole essay
this is uh
this is my new favorite coffee boss it's
the manifesto holy [__] this is chat GPT
can you write me an apology if a race is
transphobic Ulta count of mine is leaked
oh my God I don't think I've said how I
feel about being a soundboard meme on H3
so I'll say it here and then move on
my sense of humor is pretending to hold
on one sec let me just send Zach a note
I don't think I've said how I feel about
being a soundboard me on H3 so I'll say
here move on my sense of humor is
pretending to be absurd
hold on let me get through this
in the past that come into forms of
stuff like the BLM song which
uh where I pretend
Ed
where I pretend to be a black guy who
wants to kill everyone else
that sounds really good
uh that was in 2016 since then I've kept
that sense of humor but used it
in ways that aren't harmful like stop
laughing at Sonic which is Iconic we
love that one stop laughing
in other gags I make in my comedy videos
like the Zelda review I did last week
oh I haven't seen that oh
chill let me get through this bro
I love that this side of me is
highlighted on a she podcast with the
memes okay
yeah
yeah I know I mean yeah we honor you
I think it's funny okay I just don't
like when it's portrayed as how I
actually am
[Music]
telling people that all is just a it's
just an act this isn't even about the
old he's just saying like this is not
about the old he doesn't like like the
sound he's not always screaming
completely unhinged like that he's
trying to say
no one's playing it up for uh for
comedies are you [__] kidding me he
literally just this is the video he's
talking about lgbtq plus cucking pedo
Jews which is a character though this is
the awesome hilarious video you uploaded
wait what how is this about Zelda
yeah
Zelda this is 10 days ago now there's
two woke what I think it's a joke
okay because I was like I have seen the
game I don't know but still that even
with the joke that thumbnail is pretty
out of pocket brother
yeah and it's the I'm a I'm a surgeon
face
so anyway uh I love the blah blah I
really wish the H3 audience was aware
that I'm playing it up for fun and not
actually unhinged now they know okay
cool they really love the sound bites I
mean they're just fun yeah
the reason why I was open to coming on
as a guest is because I'd like to clear
that up and show the normal side of me I
did an AMA on the H3 subred last year
and his fans really enjoyed seeing right
seeing me express myself as a person and
not a living meme
which is frankly why I thought it'd be
fun to have you be a part of the live
show
I wasn't just gonna have him say one
thing it'd be more interactive than that
probably bring them up talk to him for a
little bit
so I'm sure the podcast viewers who
aren't on Reddit would also enjoy an HD
podcast episode with me as a guest yes
everybody went to the bobi episode
I love when people invite me on like or
invite themselves
your guests would love me 100
I would also have an opportunity to talk
about autism to a larger audience with
something that I think would help a lot
of his audience to hear about fair fair
you can call in and talk about this
stuff unfortunately is only interested
in using my jokes and humor to paint me
as a schizo
not a skit so also like that's not how
you spell schizo
to laugh at rather than making it clear
to joke and letting us all enjoy the
Mayhem of my Antics together with no bad
blood
I don't see Bad Blood where is the Bad
Blood no one gives a [__] about you I
don't know I just said his alt was funny
and then he freaked the [__] out I think
he's scared of what's in that
the throbbing horse [__] all account is
going to be showed on his podcast
tomorrow this is the beginning of the
part that I think should be a copy pasta
okay
so he's predicting his fate he's doing
like reading the tea leaves the
throbbing horse [__] all account is
going to be showed on this podcast
tomorrow I'm gonna be a trading like
that isn't favorable to me well to be
fair how do you portray
trans women isn't real women but I still
[__] the [__] out of them
I mean it that statement portrays itself
you know is that okay you say what you
say but it's old that was old one let's
look at the new stuff in the inside the
county existed for over 10 years and is
used to follow blocked accounts
occasionally when I was bored I'd use
the account to say absurd things with
the theme that I'm a horny guy who's
unhinged and ready to [__] anyone
including Joe Biden while saying the
n-word a lot a lot what a character
fleshed out one of my throbbing horse
[__] character attributes is that I say
the n-word that's really pushing the uh
Frontier that's what's interesting
that's his character's fatal flaw yeah
right I didn't think it would be harmful
because nobody followed the account
nobody knew it was me it was just having
fun okay okay we'll take that all into
consideration oh it kept going holy [__]
man holy [__]
I care a lot about discrimination of all
kinds and equal human rights because in
a statistic person I always feel I'm
treated as lesser to everyone else and I
never want anyone else to feel the way I
did Growing Up [__] up my self-esteem
Fair
[Music]
I'm so sad that's why I bully people on
my secret alt account
I'm so sorry to anyone who feels like
they're lesser or the punchline of a
joke because of my actions I really
don't want to hurt anyone and knowing
that my comments on that account will be
shown to 100K plus people tomorrow a lot
more than that just
see
nothing to my own horn
people tomorrow and that black viewers
will see it and feel I'm treating them
as a joke genuinely eats me up inside
Fair good good to get ahead of it yeah
my YouTube channel will be fine but I
fear my black viewers will see the
account on H3 and feel like I think
their culture is a joke well I think
this is a good
moment for reflection that I've been
through too sometimes you're like again
I always make this comparison you look
at yourself in the mirror and you think
I'm not a hateful person I love
everybody
but certain there's certain times when
you need to reflect on your action and
say even though I see myself as a good
person I am a good person right
it's this is a good time for reflection
to see like okay I perceive these as
harmless jokes but I'm not the I'm not
on the receiving ends of these so it's
not really my place to say they're
harmless or even jokes you know I mean
if you're afraid that black people will
see this and get offended then it's
probably offensive probably just
shouldn't have said it and that's okay
he's a young guy how old is Bobby
um let me see
don't say 30. no no he's younger he's uh
26.
unfuckable according to Pearl fastest
Peak
good he's good he's good his values oh
because male he's a difference
it applies to women his rules are very
different lucky you're not a woman
he says I have fourth district still has
many years to kick so Bobby says I have
felt disrespected all my life and it
makes me so sad knowing I'm going to
inflict that same feeling on other
people just because they were born with
a specific skin color so it sounds like
on one hand you want to accept
accountability and apologize but on the
other hand you're unwilling to take
accountability for it too
I think this would be I think he's close
to making a good apology even though we
haven't even talked about anything I
know I just want to see what's in there
he said to ask Ethan to please make it
crystal clear on Friday that the alt is
me playing a character for fun and it
doesn't have two followers yeah that
doesn't work bro Crystal Clear that's
not don't say that
I'm just I'm trying to be honest with
you in the sense that I I'm sympathetic
right the character defense it doesn't
work I'm just telling you and listen I'm
just telling you that and it just
doesn't work kind of Double Down dude oh
yeah so let me finish this
might talk about this in a YouTube video
if Ethan ends up showing the account
would also be a good time to address BLM
song on my main since I've never done it
I mean that's funny bro I'm sorry
we always get bullied
we always get moved
because we upload I cannot last night
so again he he says I'm just playing a
character but this isn't this is good
this is an inflection point for you this
is a point of learning which is good
sure
uh it's that's the the joke defense
doesn't work ever also
be did you and your buddies show Ethan
any Mercy when he uh you guys use that
charcoal challenge photo
I'm not I can't remember exactly if it
was him but it I can almost I might need
to know if Bobby uses that one he does
everything really I'm not gonna speak
but Bobby and I'm my Bobby I'm not even
gonna fight about me I don't know he
goes from my black challenge you
shouldn't say that he does that he he
may have not we don't know he may have
not I mean he's done and said everything
there is about me yeah that I wouldn't
usually speculate on something like that
but I mean
there's no way they actually believe all
the [__] they say there's no way like
you actually like you know these are
like childish narratives that like Keem
makes up and like it just does it for
views and I don't know he's just gone
with it for a long time so I just I'm
sorry Bobby but uh
I mean he's being a little hypocritical
expecting me to be like but at the same
time I'm not even gonna complain about
the way he's covered me I don't care I
love bobi for who he is stop
for the man who hates Sonic or loves
Sonic for everything he is I I accept
that you know if I held a grudge I was
angry about that I wouldn't I wouldn't
talk about you I want to invite you to
my show all right you know what I mean
just want nothing to do with you yeah
I'm so sorry to anyone I've heard with
my jokes please know that no matter what
you look like or feel like from birth
that you're a human just as well as
everyone else so I mean
beautiful words
uh let's take a look at the tweets
though I have one question though and I
still haven't seen it yet the the old
account but
when he's saying that it's a joke and a
character
is it clear to people just like on
Twitter seeing the tweets does it say
like parody account or you know
like why
I just wonder like how would that matter
wait you know if you put out like a
racist tweet
for example out there even if in your
head you're joking
it's still like just nobody's gonna know
let's wait as a real person to somebody
else right you're just an anonymous
poster on Twitter that's just the joke
defense Works in zero situations
just I'm just telling you that from
experience
you know as a man with lupus who's
sitting here on the Press of his demise
listening to Chestnut songs tell me I
have a lot of experience in this world
we should add the black lives matter
song to the playlist of your oh God
no the free show playlist I went too far
because we upload wait was he posting on
our subreddit is this what this is from
I show the DMS in the clip I'll show it
here too this is the DM he had with you
I mean I already I already told him that
he gets the dub on that one whatever
the DM's for me between me and blah blah
I don't care about this you get the dub
you're the man
all right so there's his apology
all right now let's go to the all that
was a lot of preparation man
here's Bobby uh with a really killer
tweet from 2020 don't say the n-word
which I agree with
I've made that mistake
all right so let's fast forward
[Music]
uh the account has since been deleted so
these here we go guys
our boy Venture into the depths of our
boy bobi AKA giant horse [__] or
whatever
Scott also look at the uh description
and this was the description as lit as
early as what like two days ago really
good vibes there's a clip in there
um below where he was caught he started
changing it but uh we caught it all
though right we got the receipts yeah
yeah Good Vibes LGBT or rainbow flag
horse uh and then the
aborigine eggplant black nine inches
hashtag n-word
it's awesome after strong start this was
from jet this is all it says 20 hours
ago so this is all like basically just
happened yesterday women always ask
weird-ass questions we [__] or no oh
he's that was the kefles damn couple's
is thick she's one of the real ones for
sure pull up and I'll provide back off
capitals tubby she needs a real nine
incher right now
and 12 likes
it's sex Coco man
I know what the [__] that means my queen
kef blocked me I'm gonna kit
kill myself by
kefla needs a man of God not this tub of
lard PM's open by the way he's quite
committed to this character he's posting
a lot
the commentary
Community is so afraid of the n-word
with a heart ER he wrote it up there
but said it all the time when idubbbz
led him this is from April 21st
this tweet is just n-word
yeah 2023 what did I say this is from
April 2023 yeah lots of n words yeah
you're mad at items in history for
saying the n word but when Beau black
says it
it's funny all right wait is this a meta
yeah criticism
it's the clearest sign that that's his
account
talking about yourself
by the way people have a right to be mad
at us for saying that that's our point
he's really gotta think for capitals yes
he does
nah bro you tripping thinking I'm a
pasty ass white cracker ass n-word Ass
blowbacks N word looks soy as [__]
testosterone all gone you feel me I
can't feel being compared to a n-word
like that when his [__] be two inches
and I'm at nine he tweeted this one
people knew it was him yeah so this is
this is post uh doxing the account
uh-huh and so this was like pseudo like
trying to deny it I guess okay he's
probably more like I don't think he
thought he could really deny it I mean
he showed it on a stream like that he
was logged into this I think he there's
certain stages of denial like trying to
own it
trying to downplay it and then and then
there's like I mean that tweet is kind
of like doubling down too yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'm seeing a bunch of people saying
it's giving Creep Show art
oh I forgot about her that's interesting
thank God she's gone what a freak that
girl was
one of the craziest exposed stories
there's like a whole Saga she was like a
commentary channel that was really nasty
about everyone to everything and then it
found out that like it was one of her
friends she was she had a uh here here
is
[Music]
right of course he has he I'm saying
anything and just a character listen any
way that you can view me in an
uncharitable light he has done really
it's just a character I don't care about
that I wasn't gonna bring it up
no but like it just adds so much flavor
to this right it's just like it's all
different things it's the salt that we
were missing right a little just a
little like salt and pepper you know a
little flavor it was kind of bland
before flavors now we got all the
textures and the flavors in there but it
is funny if you read his apology how
much he's trying to downplay it but it's
like dude no this [__] sucks just own it
just say it sucks although it's hard to
eat what it's two days ago
like you usually need a little time it's
a little slimy to
to show all of those like bad but
relatively tame ones from three totally
to like this happened like yesterday
right yeah why did it go back to the
2019 on himself yes people usually do
that you're obviously trying to kind of
yeah brush something under the rug there
a little bit I think he feels bad that
he got caught
he knows what he was doing is wrong
certainly but this was just from three
days ago so the apology is not hitting
super uh hard yeah
he says get these n-words out of my
mentions I'm not bobi he's restarted
stop spreading rumors that I'm an
autistic cracker also trans women are
real I just got mad that one of them had
a bigger [__] than me
bro you got it
you have some issues bro
that you might want to try to
perhaps work and then these ones at the
bottom are just the ones from before so
so I think that's all we got
so that's our boy Bobby
juicy juicy juicy I would say to
just work on it you know think about it
and then
probably just don't do that anymore you
know no more ultimate also yeah maybe
maybe uh wipe some of your own tweets on
your actual account because I know
there's a lot of n-bombs on there so oh
interesting yeah
they have tools it's advisable to just
delete your old tweets you know just
responding to people what's up
and word
um
really
I'm not surprised I mean uh don't say
the n-word maybe pin this tweet
pin this one
that'll be the beginning of Learning
and maturing
which I know change is considered bad in
like the in the like red pill manosphere
change is gay I guess I don't think he's
in the red pill manosphere but I want to
say here's the HP change is gay I guess
here in the ASU podcast change is good
maturing growing is good fair enough
yeah and we can all do that everything
is always changing you know we can all
do that and I think you can do it too
Boby
and so with that
I will say maybe we should play them out
with the BLM song one more time and then
give them some space to kind of just
do some reflecting um
so mean to us
might as well kill yourself
black lives matter
[Music]
oh this is just from now this is like
January January this year
at 2 30 a.m wait is that real
that tweet I mean why wouldn't it be
even if it's not these are all real wait
wait doing it from his main
oh that's from his Mane so this year
I don't know that was a skeptical yeah
it's on top right but
this is
must have been deleted
let's see
uh this is from I mean this is 2001 yeah
I mean yeah come on
whatever
2001.
I agree that white people shouldn't say
the N word in any context because it's
disrespectful for a while and in some
contexts races but we're talking about
someone who typed n-word in quotation
marks to explain how acceptable word is
she simply okay whatever
I don't care
so there it is Bobby and I like the new
look I like the haircut you know
you can Style Yourself
he looks he looks like he's got maturing
into a young man
[Music]
his hair is not like that no what does
it look like he's got long hair now wow
anyway there it is Bobby uh best of luck
to you brother
I've been down the journey
and it is a good journey it's a good
journey
yeah it's a good one
anyway guys join us this week and I'll
be over at kik.com
I'm gonna be playing slots with my good
friend Drake and train wreck TV super
super excited about that we are going to
be playing a a minimum bet 25
000. it's gonna be crazy
so hype oh by the way don't gamble do
not gamble anyway uh head on over to uh
uh steak.com and use my promo code don't
Gamble
for 100
deposit bonus
I'm gonna go to the bathroom one more
time what's my 100 million damn
we're doing my segment right yeah we'll
do that
yeah
all right I thought it was in I mean
it's pretty
pretty juicy yeah pretty juicy um we got
a ton of super chats go ahead let's read
them uh uh I'll try and get through here
uh
Claire
claims they turned 21 on Tuesday
so
Zach you you need the documentation I'm
sorry can you submit can you email Ahmad
your driver's license
you don't have to you don't have to do
that well the last girl did she showed
up somebody down the subreddit or
something it's up to Zach I can't force
you oh dude it's Friday 21. [__] you
there it is uh I would love to see an
episode where Ethan pretends to be
Donald Trump I don't know why I just
feel like it would break I mean I'm not
do a trump impression it's not good
enough for a whole yeah
I didn't want to say it but but thank
you for the donation uh candy donated a
dollar and she didn't say anything thank
you for one dollar uh electric Jesus
uh hey Ethan Ayla what's your dream
Teddy fresh IP collab even if it's not
realistically going to happen well
unfortunately Ela just walked out but
maybe
I think hasn't she said
Hello Kitty I I don't want to say Annie
because there's so many feelers out
there for different ones that actually
does like that a lot I'm not no comment
but thank you for the donation electric
Jesus 410
uh Marley donated 10 bucks and said
bring Tana on again
I love Tana we should that'd be great
that's a good idea uh yo yoanne sorry if
I'm saying that wrong Joanne uh Ethan
you're looking so good I'm so proud of
you but I hope today's show is good
unlike the rest of the trash I've
witnessed this week with peace and love
of course
we're trying
not totally successful but we're trying
in a sense in a sense
apparently if you do have leukemia
weight losses
unexplained weight loss could you know
[Music]
leukemia
did you imagine it it was probably the
right call yeah yeah that was maybe that
was a little too thumbs up I agree with
that but it was self-deprecation but
yeah still
okay
[Applause]
and I was pretty also shout out Tyler
for your 31st birthday just finished the
last one I was trying to do
all right whereas the pieces taking
forever
okay all right so um welcome to uh ELO's
makeover
again those fans of the show
we did this once before it was super fun
every crew member has customized a look
for ELA from thrift stores maximum
budget fifty dollars
so
you are going to rotate through the look
as each crew member comes up and
explains the the look and then at the
end we will vote
to see whose look is the best to himself
how are you feeling just let him cook
okay so up let's just let's just get
right into it all right just to refresh
I mean here's some of the looks
the country club slot I love them all
but you never wore any of it did you
expect me to this one gets a lot of work
the ABS
I see that Meme a lot yeah no I found a
teacher there was uh someone posted I'd
even notice that I wore something to the
crater Clash that looked exactly the
same oh yeah yeah that was sincere
Florida man
EK b y c g
uh hot at brunch oh so good Ohio man so
so here we enter Ila
um go ahead to our first contestant is
Olivia oh really whatever am I doing
this in the order that it's listed yeah
sure Olivia first oh no okay so Olivia
her and then while she's changing Olivia
to explain Okay so
I call this look
um going long on the walk to business
101.
that's what it's called nice yeah uh you
spent
46.95 so right under the threshold there
yeah yeah
very good
there are two props oh yes I do
see this might take longer than me to
get dressed it's yeah yeah maybe it's a
little harder well again I have so many
yeah yeah let's do it like 50. so I mean
if you need filler I gotta go ahead
let's do them uh let's see we have uh 14
bucks uh California bucks
from Olivia another Olivia I'm turning
26 on Sunday can I get a shout out from
the crew
uh Michael Bell donated 10 bucks and
said are you gonna play Starfield I know
I am I am officially hyped as [__] for
that well that's the uh oh uh that's the
Skyrim yeah of course I'll play that
yeah uh I was tentatively excited about
it they're like I watched their like 40
minute like little Deep dive on what
I haven't even seen anything but how
could it be bad I mean they don't really
make bad games
uh yeah this one looks like a juicer bro
a juicer uh hambone
said uh stream love songs and what you
oh oh oh
uh love stream love songs and what have
you by Zach Lewis thank you very much
our very own Zach Lewis
this week uh so thank you hambo I saw
someone go uh and chat goes I just
joined why is Ethan so grumpy and then a
person responded because he has cancer
Jesus
for anybody that wasn't here earlier
please thank you for that don't know
appreciate it uh let's see
Ira Helena is says their best friend
Iris Iris I'm doing a great job reading
these hold on let me adjust this a
little bit
uh their best friend iris is celebrating
their 20th birthday tomorrow and she's a
huge fan of the show and she would love
a shout out
[Music]
hopefully you are married with kids
because that age
I hope so thank you for the uh 30 uh
Euros for that
thank you uh
let's see Rosalia said
Topo Chicos are better anyway
thank you they're in white claws oh oh
that's an old comment gotcha
you know there's a lot of old ones here
uh
uh let's see
lzk media said PSA don't Vape
I'm two weeks Vape free and it literally
feels like chemotherapy to purge
nicotine for my brain go green yeah it's
turning out to be nicotine
vaping's turning out to be not that good
for you
I think fine I think the studies are
coming out that it's not the best uh
foxy
it's uh her first time seeing the show
live you guys are awesome keep up the
great work hey you're welcome let's see
love our live viewers don't we folks
they did do this near the beginning of
the show hopefully they haven't bailed
um
[Music]
I'm really curious what my outfit looks
on
really okay
all right here comes ela's first look
Olivia and what does this look called
Olivia going long on the walk to
business 101. wow yeah going along here
she comes
shoes get the shoes they're so important
it's quite a look
okay you want to explain this break this
down for us yeah yeah okay so we've got
like a cute Fringe Tweed skirt happening
business very business but very funky
very fresh the
um neon heels with the lace-up match the
um whatever logo is happening on that
Penny Jersey and then underneath the
penny Jersey we have a cropped Brown
ribbed
collared shirt and then we also have
music of choice coming through the Star
Wars headphones and football because she
caught it on the walk to business 101.
she's just agile like people just throw
our footballs yeah I was gonna call I
was gonna call this look radio oh that
is so mean it's ridiculous
wow radio you ever watch that movie
Radio oh no oh is it bad Oh I thought
you were saying it was so ugly it
belongs on the radio yeah that's what I
thought too I don't have a properly
describe to you the movie I'll tell you
we'll pull it up it sounds like it was
pretty nasty keep it good in junior
right radio yeah
girl from Radio wait can we try this
girl tucking in the Jersey a little bit
yeah
that's what it needed let's show it
again
going long that's working for business
101.
thank you what do we think I mean it's
interesting
I like the uh
the fusion of looks here yeah
I'll just tell you the movie is about a
guy he's handicapped he always has like
headphones on and he always has a
football
so what are you saying about ELO nothing
about you I'm talking about the outfit
all right fantastic good thank you
Olivia thank you thank you that's an
expense that's Ian's up next that was an
expensive one 46.95 but under the 50
thresh Mark so we have no complaints
she wrote that the line right there down
the you know at the peak
Ian
now Ian came in at 37.96
Ian you want to give a little uh
briefing
uh yeah I mean this one uh called an
Unexpected Journey oh yeah
I didn't know what I was doing in the
store I was very confused it was harder
to shop for ELA because with Ethan it's
like let me just buy some dumb t-shirt
right you know syllable a little more
creativity on this one and it was a
little harder an Unexpected Journey yes
it wasn't an Unexpected Journey for me I
like that that sounds promising that
sounds interesting I love that we'll see
that is the uh title of the first of The
Hobbit trilogy is it not what I don't
know Unexpected Journey yeah you know
how they during The Hobbit into three
movies oh the hot okay okay I thought
you're yeah not Lord of the Rings yes
yeah no the bad ones
what well she has comments Ian yes what
was the what was that are the two shirts
two options to choose from or like to
layer on top of each other no you but
the button all the top and then the vest
and then the other thing on top of it on
top okay does that make sense it's a
triple threat yeah
apparently insiders put an article on
Pearl
did they put it down
and they did uh Dextero did one as well
oh really
anti-feminist YouTuber Pearl says she
thinks divorce should be illegal and
women shouldn't have the right to vote
amen sister
there's no shoes with this one yeah no
shoes on this one whenever these
Publications talk about me they go
controversial YouTuber Ethan Klein
right yeah I see that in say that here
but they probably did in the article
right let's see I think they called her
controversial right yeah in this world
reversal uh on HP podcast Pearl Davis
doubled down on many of our
controversial views she said she thinks
the verse should be illegal Davis
Champions are increasingly significant
online community which she thinks women
have too many rights
we gotta scale back those damn rights
having a hard time in there uh Ian do
you have any notes or encouragement for
her it's a complex sort of Ensemble it's
an odd Journey that's an Unexpected
Journey
I just what seems to be the issue
[Music]
there's something going on here it's
giving me it's giving me Willy Wonka
yeah maybe tuck in the black shirt or
yeah
there's something yeah dude I I swear
I've seen this outfit somewhere it's a
panic at the disco music video This is
Johnny Depp uh Willy Wonka that's how
they dress at the cinema yes so I I
found the jacket and I liked it and then
I saw the interesting Ethan or something
yeah I saw the pants I like the pants
and then I realized I was kind of just
styling
Bilbo Baggins a little bit so I kind of
just went out for it interesting title
then it looks like the Blazer I wore at
the Roxy
yeah so you got that building
no she is no shoes that's part of The
Hobbit Vibe yeah I realized you know no
shoes for pillows yo yo ELO Don't show
your bare feet like that
you if you get a show feed you better
charge
[Applause]
that's all I'm gonna say
I mean a pipe would definitely
accommodate it like a long pipe a cane
perhaps
yeah
um
a registration on the sex offender list
so you're saying this is a bad fit are
you ELO you going to say that really
okay you could say it you're going to
say that really pretty mean it was a 37
look no I'm not gonna say that okay good
good fit all right very good I'm not
gonna say that
it's unexpected unexpected he went on an
Unexpected Journey I think the hat is
super special I'm looking for a hat
thank you Ian thank you Ela
up next we have Zach now Zach is a
bargain shopper Zach spent the least of
anyone coming in at
22.97 my God less than half of your
budget was spent Zach how do you explain
it I found some really cool [__] and um
that's all I needed 22 look yeah well I
can't wait to see that yeah I'm very
excited
fantastic
yeah um
for it
um Palm Spring Chic didn't you do the
same thing for me yes kind I think so
which is Zach an Unexpected Journey
which is Ian and going on
going long on the walk to business 101.
okay wait I have to show this I love
this
new Frenemies just dropped Shredder and
kayak oh my God that's so cute I love
that food it's so cute
try to look so cute there
oh my God I love them Ryan or Harvey's
the goat
new Frenemies yes oh so this clip of
Howie which is on I can't
we watch it did you deep fry it cam uh I
tried I deep-fried it to a comical
degree but yeah give me that one uh okay
if that works yeah I mean it's not going
to read as it was hold on it's that bad
now I'm just curious well I I did it as
a gag because nothing else was working
before so anyway in this scene which
I'll I'll just play like for a split
second it's done our subreddit
um
okay go ahead I'll explain this
afterwards either come on out this is
Zach's look wow
this is a 22 look I'm telling you dude
look at the jacket shirt's got a nice
little story to it my life story will be
a good one it says and then the pants
are flowy and uh comfy and it's great
for summer Egyptian kind of what's the
what's the connection here with the
butterflies and the Egyptian I don't
know I like patterns a lot so
um that's what I was going for and uh it
doesn't look bad
oh
I'm not hating it to be honest you're
not I'm not loving it obviously but it's
a 22 look
I mean why didn't you get shoes back you
had some more money to spare good
question I like the outfit Springs you
don't always need shoes Coachella you
could wear it to go yeah you know the
concrete it's nice and cool to the foot
yeah yeah
scorpions rattlesnakes
okay fantastic all right that is Zach's
Palm Springs look for ELA Klein thank
you ELO thank you Zach up next we have
Samantha
from the temple
Legends of the temple remember that show
Nickelodeon yeah Legends of the temple I
always wanted to be on it
Samantha Legends of the temple here let
me show you what I did she has spent
48.94
right at the edge but you know she went
all out with her budget and uh I'm
looking forward to what she cooked up
here's the here's our deep fried version
of uh
this clip
so it's Howie on a um a crane
what am I even looking at I was just
this is the best I could do
so here's the clip Howie on the crane
let's take a look freaks out
[Music]
are we underwater
it looks like the Titanic has maybe
sinking
[Music]
so okay now I'll say this
obviously this is fair use uh because I
believe we're having a valuable
commentary over it but in an effort to
not get blocked cam has done his best
efforts to deep fry this
and so how we had this moment I guess on
True TV was it Impractical Jokers thing
what was it
and uh he was on the crane and he
started freaking the [__] out he was
like get me down I didn't sign up for
this
uh go back to the show I can't do this
and genuinely freaking the [__] out
and um
I asked Howie I said is this a bid or is
this real and how he said to me verbatim
that was one of the worst moments of my
whole career
he's real
I feel bad for him man
uh that they did him dirty like that and
I really tried to make it subtle with
the block and everything but I had to go
all out to make sure it didn't get
blocked in so it was unbelievable no it
was good I mean I felt uh I felt a real
connection to the the footage I feel
something good so whose outfit is uh ELO
changing into right now this is Sam from
the temple Sam do you want to come sit
next to Ethan and explain yours
so Ela how's it going you need help
ready all right ELO come on putting on
the left that is gonna kill me
oh no he was said it's interesting but
not in a way that
I would have liked to let's see
Okay girl okay I call this lemon and
lime at the Polo Club
[Applause]
kind of slaying yeah it's kind of I
imagine this skirt to be a little bit
shorter but
I don't know what do we think let me see
the shoes oh wow
wow the shoes are a sleigh this is a 48
outfit let me tell you that looks like a
expensive outfit look at that oh where
are the sunglasses
what we're missing something that's
important I'll be fair
oh that is that is
interesting that there's no there's no
classes in that
back
um there was definitely sunglasses but
just imagine just imagine it
so here's Ela feeling herself what is
the name of this look again
uh women in Lime at the Polo Club Polo
Club yeah I like the polo now lemon and
lime at the polo the hat is giving me
like Polo Club are we talking horseback
yes yes yeah yeah I'm feeling that I've
never been to a polo club but I imagine
this is what I would wear you look
classy yeah okay you could play a round
of golf you could be a spectator at a
tennis event you could be on Horseback
playing Polo or spectating
I can't see you uh
you got the old-timey kind of newspaper
cap
it's an old I originally had different
boots and
um when they rang up everything the
total was 79. and I was like what but
the boots I got were 49 at Goodwill so
they were so fire sometimes well prices
are they're not gonna change sometimes I
know well they were like some designer
but oh I had to I had to rework my whole
outfit all right well wonderful very
nice and did you say the price on that
one Ethan yeah one more time the price
is 48.94 right below the threshold
welcome nailed it all right on that line
so we have eight total we're through
half of them so I'm gonna throw up the
pole for the first four
right all right we have Olivia's give me
one sec I got a graphic I'm just gonna
finish it what was yours Olivia
you have a grab before the poll well
just if people want to like visually
review I was thinking oh oh oh good
that'll help
it's a little messy but it's it's a good
job
all right I'll throw this up on my
screen again so we've got get your votes
in guys for the first bracket Olivia's
uh going
long the business 101.
um then we've got uh Ian's an Unexpected
Journey
we've got Zach's Palm Springs Chic and
finally Sam with the lemon and lime Polo
Club look we have four very different
looks all within the 50 range well done
to them now this is tough I'm I'm really
gotta search my soul here for
is the pole up already
the poll is up I want to vote on this
there is a clear winner
I'm searching my soul on this one and my
vote is might surprise you but I know
which one I'm voting for
oh
okay
I guess it wasn't that odd I went for
the first one I did Olivia's I thought
it was kind of you like Olivia I thought
it was kind of interesting oh it looks
like that one's in second
yeah but so we have a clear winner and
it is even actually trending up a little
bit but uh Sam's is uh 30 points ahead I
think it's pretty clear Sam you took it
down by far well hold on give mine a
second okay Ian is in last place
actually give it a second I believe Ian
was Crown Champion uh when we did it
with you Ethan and he appears I'm
surprised he's struggling this yeah I
don't think I've ever seen you this low
on the polls before again an Unexpected
Journey indeed listen
and I saw some people in the chat and
maybe this isn't totally clear but the
goal is to either find a great outfit or
a funny outfit sure yeah you know what I
mean and so he went for the fun I went
with the great outfit yeah
well there it is my mind is similarly
leaning into a certain theme that I
wouldn't necessarily expect to be able
to uh dress up as so congratulations Sam
for winning the first bracket moving on
now to uh ABS up next now A B I have to
ask you
[Music]
you know I figured since it's my turn I
just bring this out right now hold on
guys we're about the pizza over there
holy [__] what is that
oh
kale and sausage yeah I'm gonna try that
what the [__]
oh you know this place yeah what's it
called prime pizza
so yeah mine went over budget slightly
[Applause]
hold that thought hold up hold on Amy
let them cook yes
cheers my dude
Pizza
no it is really good
so Abe you win seven dollars over a bike
here what do we say about what do we
think about this
so yeah last time I was trying so hard
to go under budget but then when we did
it it didn't really matter that much to
go over a little so I was like all right
because I really wanted this jacket that
that ela's about to walk out in so yeah
I went eight dollars over budget okay
well let's take that will that could be
considered in the finale we're gonna
have to dock you we might have to dock
but come out either yeah
oh my goodness
you really that went in for the detail
okay what you got shoes let me see this
yeah let me see
wow
Samantha is sweating
what do you call this I call this Donnie
Brosco
because I thought of the uh I just
realized we need a main purpose gives me
Donnie Brasco bro I'm impressed that
outfit's pretty nice yeah glasses too
yeah
holy [__] who is she CEO I want her I
need her
I want to moan you legally literally I
want documents
very good thank you thank you thank you
I gotta say man
this jacket is pretty sick
very good well done very impressed
that's ab's uh what is it
all right so Donny Bros or it's Brasco
right is that Donnie Brosco
no it's with an a it's Brasco up next is
Lena
who spent 43.96
you want to come
give us a scoop Lena I'm I'm still
surprised by a b
yeah that's a hell of a look he put
together I mean and was that at a
Goodwill as well maybe or did you go to
a different
it was Goodwill nice
I'm surprised you got that for him
Health 56 dollars
I've never seen someone carry Pizza like
that before dude was carrying it like a
briefcase like sideways
me and Lena uh eat cheese only so I was
trying to grab us some cheeses but yeah
um
yeah I really like the jacket so I just
worked around that but that was half the
budget which was a little the jacket put
it all together frankly yeah the jacket
I worked around the jacket yeah well
done I I also that seems like the way to
go is you find like kind of a
centerpiece and then yeah you build
around that
Selena how are you feeling what what
tell us about your look I feel confident
even if it doesn't win it's still a
great look and I know ELO's gonna look
fabulous in it mine is what I like to
call Pretty in Pink oh Pretty in Pink
okay right now all right and that will
be Lena
is that it's very versatile
I mean ELO's a busy lady so she can wear
this to lunch and then she can go to a
red carpet event it's like oh wow you
can wear it anywhere a versatile look
beautiful Timeless Timeless versatile
what is in this book
not at all
Ela says oh cute she's
making live comments
I need to ask all of our guests I'm
going to ask them the first thing tell
me do you think slavery in America was
embellished
see how we usually it is to answer that
question
even Oliver got that right
um all right come on out Pretty in Pink
whoa
is there shoes yes I love it
I like it okay hold the phone this is
looking very very nice very very nice
and the bag is so Ela because she loves
small things that's so cute the shoes
are so cute is that why you like me
thanks Ellen
[Music]
also my last name's climb which is small
I never thought about that
I love it that's a beautiful look yeah
thank you thank you guys it is you're
right it's glossy it's Timeless yeah
for real Chanel for real you are Chanel
you are the moment
Miss Coco
what would you keep in that bag if you
were this woman
sir
what was your answer Chanel Number Five
baby
yeah pepper spray Canal number pepper
spray yeah
he's beautiful but don't let that glue
he's also Street Mart street smart she
has bear spray in her purse
I love it cool stiff competition on the
lower back beautiful love we don't [__]
around
did you guys shop together or separately
we went the same time but separately you
guys both yeah look at YouTube huh
well beautiful you look
don't go ahead so up next
we have
coming up Cameron
now cam our good friend cam has like a b
gun over budget
55.20
now we may have to penalize him if it
comes down to the finals
that's fine there's a reason for it too
but
it is what it is
um one of the items was unmarked and I
had to get a price check and I rolled
the dice and it just happened
oof what set it over and I said tell me
about your look yeah what's it called uh
it's called Primary in Winter because
lately I've been using a lot of primary
colors in my Sketchbook and Winter's my
favorite season so I wanted to do a nice
little winter look wow okay
winter Primary in winter
fantastic absolutely
that's all I gotta say about that that's
all you need to say
no more
say no less
say exactly what you said
yeah love ya no homo
oh I can I give you guys another Channel
recommendation
maybe some of you guys know what's her
name uh I suggest I was playing Diablo
last night and sometimes you're just
looking for
you know I think this is what people use
the show for and so I get it
obviously I can't watch my own show
right but I'm playing Diablo and I just
really want something to play
and something along to entertain me
and this girl I think her name is immune
cat
I saw it in the subscript uh the this
video suggestion bar she had this one
video
um
I debunked the entire manosphere oh yeah
I've seen her I saved it for later
she's so good she's so funny her videos
are crazy
it's like a two hour long video
somehow like her interests are insanely
similar to mine like she has one about
garyvee like she's one of the only other
people I've seen on the internet calling
out garyvee and she roasts him so
[__] good
she has a really good video about web3
she's good she's really cool so she's
she's a great watch but obviously watch
our podcast before any of that [__]
when I recommend channels like the guy
the other day and her just remember them
don't not instead of this
clearly
yeah
so shout out to immune cat
uh what flavors do we have well here
let's do this ELO come on out all
different ladies this is Cameron's
Primary in Winter okay Sex in the City
giving me
kind of it's like sex in the uh well
it's more like sex in the Goodwill
in the forest
so what do we have we have a flannel
[Music]
we have a
fluffy coat
I gotta be honest this one's pretty all
over the place yeah
[Music]
Sam said very Wes Anderson off off the
mic I'll take it yeah that's a good
comment
that couldn't be bad right okay how do
you feel
um I feel like I'm wearing Cam's
clothing yeah well that's
well that's strange in the ladies
section as my own as a bearded dude um
so I kind of just stuck to
what I felt like I would wear yeah
I mean it doesn't look bad frankly the
pants
the top looks good I don't know what's
going on with the pants they seem
s short maybe they're
it's hard to get pant size too yeah it
is but there it is there it is Cameron's
uh
sexless in the city more like how about
that
someone said sex in the Goodwill next in
the Goodwill yes
very good Cameron finally we have up
next
the one the only
the hater the wizard you know by many
different names don't build it up too
much
you love them you hate him I can't stand
some can't stand him some love him Dan
who spent 33.95 well done on the budget
well so first of all shout out to Ally
she went with me and helped
um couldn't have done it without you
um
the Goodwill that we went to uh they
were like cleared out it was weird there
weren't that many options but
then
we found a pair of shoes that we decided
to build around okay
um this is definitely not a um
is leaning more towards the inside of
the spectrum I would say
um rather than the uh Sam or Lena
um but I don't know maybe it's some
people's Vibe you know what's funny is
my original idea when we were looking
around was to do like an early 90s like
Riot girl like Courtney Love kind of
look and I'm glad I didn't because Ela
walked in today wearing basically that
look uh today so that would have been a
little bit disappointing
um so the look that I am doing I'm
calling um the Rod Stewart groupie the
Rod Stewart groupie
she's backstage after the Rod Stewart
concert she's got her record she's
looking for an autograph and maybe maybe
a little more we'll see where the Knight
takes us yeah and one of the songs on
the record is called hot legs so you
know
[Music]
that's right
so are you you brought me options
no this is great thank you so much
but also it was uh I thought I was over
it was at like 55. went to check out and
like half of my stuff was on the the
purple tag sale or whatever it was like
a dollar yeah so that's why mine you
ended up like super low yep well done 33
95. yes sir
that rupee the Rod Stewart groupie
Gila says the shoes are tiny oh okay
you can't get a mom we can uh squeeze
them in there wait the shoes are
everything the shoes are kind of
everything
he's working
he left this pizza spot it's good
um um I have some bad news
Kevin
not Kevin donated ten dollars said Ethan
another subpar showing
you uh you lied to us said today would
be different
oh at least he didn't wish me to die
that's what I expected from Kevin oh
okay yeah I'm relieved at least you just
said the show sucks
you Kevin
save your money
go donate to like Aiden Ross or some
[__] okay
we got it
cannot get anybody Here Comes elope the
groupie he's coming out
she's got the dress she's got the record
and the shoes which is the most
important part this is your imagination
oh yeah
we love you
Rod Stewart
we got it first we got a jacket look on
the inside of the purse
there's something inside the purse Ela
it's not really that there's something
inside but it's it's a gun
she's there to assassinate Rod Stewart
that's right no no I was just saying the
uh the lining in the purse matching the
shoes yeah it's right it matches
important details things are all
together important details
yeah very good yeah I mean I like it
it's not a bad look for sure yeah red
right in fact if the shoes fit
and it's pretty nice yeah I had a
feeling
but like I said we were really looking
for a centerpiece item and those shoes
were like the only thing in the store
that were like damn these are wild I'll
do something with this I think you did
well yeah all right well thank you thank
you you're not really a joke yeah no uh
yeah I would attribute that mostly to
ali
um it's not at all a jokey out there
gee she has a better sense of style than
me so she she helped pick out some cute
stuff
what's happening oh she got she's taking
the shoes off yeah all good go for it
well that includes the showing yep
so let's throw up the second bracket uh
cam are you uh cooking me up another
little infographic I think I'm just
finishing yours up right he's almost
done thank you give me one second
so the bottom bracket which we're about
to throw up has a b Lena and wins and
Dan huh
I don't think
who said Dan wins I'm just seeing some
people in the chat some people in the
chat really liked it so
I think for my money I'm not gonna say I
don't I don't wanna
there's some there's some leaders though
in my mind strong bracket frankly you
all put a nice outfits together
here we are thank you
here we are we have ab's Johnny
Brassfield
all right excuse me
which did you like best
ask the community here we go Lena's
Pretty in Pink
cams
uh sexless in New York
Texas in the city
and dance
the Rod Stewart groupie strong strong
contenders oh
let's see
okay
so I can tell you who's in last
with six percent
is a cam
sorry about that cam it happens
you're still the most talented Camp I
don't know about that but third place
Rod Stewart's groupie Dan Dan with 12
percent
second place
Pretty in Pink
Lena's
beautiful look 33 I voted for that one
but the winner is and talk about an
Unexpected Journey it's a B's look
Donnie Brasco who is she that was my
vote
that was a fire outfit well done Amy
thank you guys damn
for the record I voted for you Dan love
Rod Stewart I figured you'd like that
vibe
and back
to Courtney Love Style
it really wasn't my original concept
really would have looked something like
that
so now that we have our finalists
we have to pit a b yeah win over we got
the runoff maybe did go over let's be
let's be fair
oh true
doesn't matter he went over there's
rules
so it's who won the first bracket Sam so
Sam was under
I think we need to we need to do this so
we have Sam versaby can you give me a
graphic for that uh cam yeah throw those
two together now Sam's was 48.94 ABS was
56.95 there we need to establish a game
I think we need to handicap a b because
of the Miss spend
I would do six percent handicap one
dollar for each one point for each
dollar hmm
I remember you emphasizing this last
time
well last time I didn't like how
you know
last time
I'm just trying to punish you
I'm just I just want to punish I think
the winner last time went over
I think Sam deserves it okay stop all
right we got the graphic I mean on
screen maybe I thought you put together
a really nice outfit oh thank you Sam
I've said that too I like the glasses a
lot now you got to put out this glasses
or what put me over and that's why I I
was checking out and I saw them at the
counter I'm like oh those are perfect
they were both very fire for spending
under fifty dollars I would say they did
not AB did not spend under 50. uh right
which is why we're docking him uh like
20 points or so from I was thinking one
point for each dollar
one point for each dollar over 50. yeah
and what was he at he's at
he's at 56.95 but I'll do six I'll
settle for so he needs to win by six
points yeah interesting and of course
this is part of the conspiracy in avi's
mind to prevent him from achieving from
any kind of thing yeah let's just let
him have it
well we don't even know who's winning
let's find out I just threw up the poll
here we go now Ela do you have a
favorite as the finals are underway yeah
what's your pick do you want me to weigh
yeah sure of course okay
[Music]
I do like both of them if I had
it would be abs
there you go thank you all right hey
babe I want to tell you something I
voted for you thank you so you can
apologize to me after the show I'm just
playing along with the meme I'm just I'm
I'm just kidding
no I I knew that uh
I have a feeling you liked mine go on I
can see it in your eyes
but the good news is
a b took it down so hard even with that
handicap 71 percent the six percent lock
the door I'm gonna break it
on 80's beautiful Donnie Brasco who is
she
and I'm the real winner because I get to
go home with her let's go
let's go I gotta say Abby I'm impressed
thank you well done it was all the
jacket but Sam's was great Sam had a Sam
had a very nice fit
did not expect it my second favorite of
all the looks frankly was Lena's
thank you very much it was a tough it
was tough that you guys got
paired up together
I'm Gonna Stand by mine I thought mine
was pretty cool
it was it was very creative I voted for
years in the top record thank you
I kind of are people saying bad pull
there's two choices the ABS are saying
people are excusing to be of stealing
the glasses
oh I don't know I don't know where the
sunglasses went I know they're on the
receipt uh maybe they fell out in my car
AB did you hide them did you hide the
glasses do rigged the competition I'm
not I'm not just [__] interesting I
noticed ab's look had glasses
I did notice that as well very
interesting all right well I'm calling
the poll uh did anyone have a heart
attack or was there a fire at Goodwill
as you were waiting the glasses counted
under the fifty dollars
on Sam's
oh she's still under 50 even with so
where are the glasses who took the
glasses took the dance question
who would benefit the most from the
glasses disappearing
I'm kidding well done babe thank you
nice thank you you are the man
glory is yours
mm-hmm
for that three hours let me see we
didn't talk about Andrew Tate I guess we
could just take it out of the [__]
title
I kind of want to finish up the uh the
just pearly things
because she started
um coping hard on Twitter yeah I want to
see yeah I haven't seen it at all so
let's see
should we just take Tate out
L Tate yeah
getting divorced should be illegal and a
stand on this hill you should work it
out Point Blank period
it's not about you anymore it's about
children
so stupid
do you know the kids do you know the
situation like how can you make such an
an absolute statement
it's insane to me but she's not serious
she can't be serious
yeah divorce should be illegal also
there's something about that statement
too
that I should have asked you
kind of the most disturbing part is this
is that she's in favor of the government
being the sole decider
right on something as personal as a
marriage the government forbids you
um
to get divorced they're forcing you to
stay married so what else can the
government do
in your personal life
you know what I mean
you can't be serious
he said chores is a stupid reason to get
divorced and should be shamed he had no
[__] dumbass nobody gets [__]
divorced because of chores you [__]
what a dumbass thing to say
to this day I don't know what I would do
without my dad's leadership
my dad is the best person I know anytime
I haven't listened to my dad I was
always wrong
okay cool for you
well I'll tell you this if your dad's
responsible for the who you are today
then he definitely failed
you might need to re-review your
relationship with him
also you're single you don't have kids
but also you're like going down every
day nice for you if you feel that you
have that kind of relationship with your
dad not everybody is that lucky though
I can't imagine it having a terrible dad
stop calling your husband your partner
we are not equal
she's not serious right
we her not real husband
yeah I don't think you have a husband
yeah I think you're single as [__] I
think so too I feel like she shouldn't
be allowed to say we because we are not
equal yeah us and her true yeah I notice
she does that a lot too she goes we when
she talks about women
to woman we are not equal not you
we not you yeah
sad she's really a shame yeah the left
things
technological progress and better
standards of living is worth the
destruction of the family they'll lie to
you to fit the agenda to no end well I
don't even know what you're saying
you're just making [__] up I'd love to
take her shopping
maybe wait better standard of living is
she again better standard of living no
are we against better standard of living
[Music]
if you're having a better standard of
living that implies that whatever's
going on in your
that's good we want that
and yes destroy the family I'm against
family
I think kids should grow up by
themselves like goddamn [__] sharks
I think the mom should give birth and
then bail
oh that was loud
sorry but I'm passionate about this
they should have a baby on the sidewalk
and walk the [__] away
that's what I'm in favor of
family is for losers and
is she divorced no I don't think she's
ever even been married she didn't even
get that far
not divorce
I don't even think she's ever been in a
long-term relationship period she can't
yeah it's not possible because she's all
uh deal with it no matter what so
but she goes
my problem with dating is any guy that
would be interested in me is pathetic
I would never date a guy who would be
interested in me yeah
interesting Theory we need to get that
confidence up
we live in a culture where it's
acceptable to be little your husband in
public and refer to him as child no we
don't
literally don't
I can't even I don't I don't recall ever
even seeing that
but
sanction all success in technology
technological advancements mean nothing
without family I'm getting a Timothy
McVeigh Vibes here
I'm I'm feeling maybe Unabomber
on the technology thing
we gotta see if she has a Hut in the
forest Run
suburbs of Chicago
I don't think she's smart enough to
build a bomb or anything like that so
it's good
we live in a generation of selfish
idiots who think that their happiness is
more important than children children
are innocent bystanders who deserve to
be protected now why haven't you had
children already
what are you waiting for because nobody
wants her why you're so selfish idiot
they deserve a mother and a father under
the same roof even if that father is
raping them and getting them pregnant
and beating their mom up they deserve
that she's so selfish
yeah she is
she's up three she could easily have
four kids by now at 26. yeah you're
scared
yeah
she's like scraping for validation from
the world's worst men ever and not even
they they won't give it to her anything
to do with it because the men that she's
appealing to
are the most shallow men in the world
these red pill manospheres the only
thing they value is a woman's looks and
apparently virginity which is creepy and
weird as [__] yeah and age
so of course the men that she's
appealing to are going to confirm her
worldview worldview bias that all men
are like that and by the definition none
of those men are going to want her right
yep none of them
sorry Pearl black girl hours real black
girl hours this is yeah abortion should
be illegal in all cases Point Blank
mothers who break this should go to
prison okay
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy you
should go to prison for not having a
baby
I mean
yeah maybe you know yeah maybe she saw
this working for like Ollie London they
that's the right uses uh him as an
example against trans people and then uh
you know like David Rubin with gay
people now they found their woman to uh
the hard part about her is like
with Dave Reuben I can kind of believe
that he's that dumb
Ali London hmm it's harder to admit that
he's not a total grifter but she's just
like a comic book character yeah it's
like cartoonishly stupid
nobody's even buying this [__] it's so
stupid with David I wasn't sure until he
did that interview with Ben Shapiro when
they were sitting together I was like oh
no he's just clueless oh when did when
Ben was like I would not go to your
anniversary yeah he's like yeah you'd
come to my wedding I get it man
he's like you know hey and that he goes
and that's your right I'm glad we can
sit and talk about how you don't think
that my relationship is valid pull that
up Dave
Rubin is the probably the most pathetic
man that's ever lived ever in all human
history
he is a gay man who was trying to adopt
a child and his own fans turned on him
because he wanted a child with his with
his partner
and he's like I get it you guys yeah
it's [__] up he goes yeah his audience
is conservative okay and he's gay
and he says [__] like I get it a lot of
people abuse the system you know you're
usually right about this
he oh my God he's the best that's it
I'm gonna wait for that clip so good
but Pearl says most mothers don't even
raise their kids they send them to
daycare school or Nannies the [__] Mo
again you're just saying [__]
so she wants women to not work
I which is ironic because she works
right and her mom works right she's just
a walk-in contradiction like I said and
it's just like nothing makes sense this
is so good watch this Gila
Dave Rubin
has no soul
this man would walk into a gas chamber
willingly and be like I get it
I get it you know it's weird to be gay
man it's harder on it's harder on but
again that appeals that applies to a
wide variety of sins that I mean listen
it's harder on it's harder on members of
my family than anybody else I've said
before I wouldn't attend an
intermarriage hold on right did you
marry an Andrew
no
no no he just sounds like that I'm
hoping this was the most replayed part
so I'm hoping this is the right part but
uh go ahead an intermarriage so this is
exactly the same issue
God damn it oh it's a Kyle Kolinski yeah
I I have another time stamp from a
different interview I think this is well
because there's there was two times
because he wouldn't go to his wedding
and then he came on later and asked if
he would go to his anniversary he was
like no I won't do that either here
because it's 50 50. I can't bake you a
cake which mine is real quiet chef and
he would have done it kosher the whole
thing yeah this is it okay okay so if
you wouldn't bake me a cake that's okay
and now because it's 50. I'm gonna go
back a little bit foundation and the
foundational ones but I do think that
you know how you raise your kids
religiously and and with regard to
things like morality does actually have
to be at the root of how you teach your
kids yeah so if you have deep if you
have deep divisions with your spouse on
these issues I think that and you're
looking to build a family anyway yeah
then I think that these are issues where
building on a bad Foundation is a bad
move so let me okay so if you wouldn't
bake me a cake that's okay and now
because it's 50 50. I can't bake you a
cake which David
chef and he would have done it the whole
way man yeah yeah he was saying he
wouldn't even make him a cake
um if we were having an anniversary
party would you come if I was inviting
all the crew that we all know and we
were just an anniversary party we're
just having a party and uh and I'll even
throw in some kosher food for you I
think Dave is actually trying to invite
him to a party yeah why are you trying
so hard he's desperate he's so desperate
to be liked he wants on his show started
crying about how Joe Rogan hasn't
invited him back because I've reached
out my PR people have reached out I
don't know what's up Joe just won't
answer my
yeah that's that's a different thing
well it not really because again it's if
you're a religious person you're gonna
take it from the religious perspective
that from the religious perspective the
question is are you glorifying something
that you think is sinful yeah so if it's
a party for something that you think was
originally sinful can you participate in
that so from a religious point of view
that's an actual serious moral question
yeah what I got to dinner with you the
answer is yes right because that's not
actually like let's celebrate something
that I feel that you're doing is sinful
but I'd have to I'd have to think about
that one I'm being a perfectly honestly
as straightforward as possible so it's
see that's so interesting to me because
it's like if I threw a regular party
just having a party at my house and all
the guys
I'd make you a cake that had nothing to
do with the gay wedding right and I
would go to a party with you that has
nothing to do with gay marriage would
you make me a regular cake could I just
have a Thursday yeah
I'll just buy you one yeah Shapiro cake
and then I'm gonna write then once I get
it here
it'll be there all right let's see
there's a lot there you know we'll keep
talking about forever and it's all right
exactly all right let's see it's so
interesting uh you know that's so
interesting that you so interesting I
think that I'm an Abomination yeah you
wouldn't even come to my home because
I'm so disgusted by me it's so
interesting I just love how he tried to
cover him he's like all right so you
won't bake me a cake because it's
celebrating my marriage but you'll just
you'll hang out with me like yeah
anniversary and just constantly trying
to cover for it can we just watch TV a
little
it's like just come watch with me
something
and then there's uh dude you've seen the
Larry King moment that's [__]
internet
history when Larry King takes a call in
the middle of a Dave Rubin interview
right yes yes I watched that again
recently it's so good
it's so good
um anyway whatever
so
back to just purely if you have some
other Dave Rubin moments I'm here for it
back to her tweet about mothers don't
even raise their kids to send them to
daycare school or Nannies
what is she thinking that like
how is the couple supposed to raise
their kid when you need to work in order
to make money to pay for the kid hold on
she goes on and on about how she had Au
pairs her whole life because her mom's
like a president her ass was raised by
[__] nannies yeah I was tempted to
comment like girl we know we already
know that you were raised by Au pairs
from all over the world you said it we
did research on it but she talks about
having children is very expensive yeah
it's very expensive a lot of couples
cannot afford it with just one salary
both parents have to work she's
literally the dumbest person
uh men are Superior Building Society and
leading relationships okay whatever
there's a woman in the UK who took
abortion pills at eight months pregnant
and was jailed for it I say good that's
just cutting Locker up I think most
people agree that aborting a bit no
everybody agrees I think I'm boarding
aborting a baby is [__] up why is she
talking about the exceptions but she
always goes the left wants to kill baby
one day before they're born and it's
legal it's like no nobody anywhere in
the United States I don't think is
widely advocating for that and nowhere
is it even legal to do that in the whole
of the United States
um
okay I'm doing a show tonight on what
should on what should you endure in
America this is the indoors I'll be live
in uh 20 minutes I've had peace after
hit peace after hit piece on me but I
won't stop saying what's true
the left will harass my friends my
family threaten me insult me but
everything we fight for is inherently
good we believe in Freedom and family
what Freedom you're saying you cannot no
abortions you can't divorce everything
how is that freedom restricting Freedom
so what does she mean actually I do
wonder what does she mean by freedom
because she even put Freedom before
family so it's even more know anything
about anything it's just all [__]
she's yeah he believes in the freedom to
control everybody else
the left will continue to shame me for
not believing in marriage family and
purity
you don't believe in marriage
they will mock it and Gaslight you into
thinking these are not good things the
lefts are evil people who want to see
Society crumble good Nuance take there
Pearl
no woman
no women do not deserve child support
when they divorce their husband I was
thinking about this does the child
deserve child support right does she
know I yeah I thought she should know
how much it costs to have a kid that's
what I was wondering she was like the
woman is not entitled to child support
it's like baby the child is entitled to
the Sephora man [__] them kids how is
the child gonna pay for their school and
everything she grew up extremely wealthy
yeah there's no contest there's no
concept of anything there there's all
this leftist propaganda that you always
need a backup plan in marriage in case
it doesn't work out that's not true who
goes get married but have a backup plan
literally when have you ever heard that
psychotic
okay here it comes about me H3 is so
stupid they didn't realize my mom was
the president of their company but my
dad was the CEO my mom left her job as a
teacher to work at the business my dad
started it was a family business why are
they bringing up my family debate so
she's trying to minimize her mom's
involvement in a effort to be consistent
she goes
okay my mom may have been president but
we were just doing that to commit tax
fraud my dad was the one that was
actually in charge
and I I really I was baffled by this one
I mean not just this one but we didn't
say that like what is she correcting in
this tweet her mom was President right
that which is what we said yeah so
what's
why am I what's the problem what a way
the start H3 is so stupid they didn't
realize my mom was the president that's
what we said as the CEO it's like Ethan
said we were giving her mom too much
credit she's saying yeah chill out my
mom is a [__] idiot really the
context of women that's how she heard it
but okay if you believe in divorced then
don't get married
if you're homeless buy a house right
exactly
we have an entire generation that has
been lied to by their mothers Tashi
hates women yeah your father isn't the
bad guy she paints her mouth to be what
did her mom do to her you know like She
[__] hates her mom hates her mom she
loves her dad yeah
but they're still married
I bet her mom wishes she believed in
divorce
ask him for his side of the story
someday okay
we have an entire generation I I just
read that she retweeted this the woman
says she believes in divorce if one
partner grows and the other one doesn't
that's a massive red flag
yeah
yeah talk about stuff before you get
married is that what you mean like make
sure you have common your values line up
it's assumed the wife won't change or
grow and that's fine and it's assumed
that men will often grow in his career
okay
no you don't that's the that's the
theory of conservative politics no
change we want no change
backwards change but if the man grows
then it's good it's a it's growth in his
career right that's what she's saying no
you don't have authority over your
husband in a marriage nobody said that
instead of getting divorced you should
learn this she dude she was having like
a [__] mental break this is all
within like 30 minutes spam that's crazy
that's a lot the earlier ones were I
mean these are all within you can see
the timestamps these are 17 hours the
rest was 22 hours ago so yeah she was
definitely spiraling yeah she was
definitely instead of getting divorced
you should learn to stop arguing with
your husband that's good advice just
why is divorce always a woman's idea
don't you aren't you familiar with the
stats don't you understand that you're
right I'm stupid men that promote
promiscuity for women are evil
she's talking about me they know men are
not looking to marry hoes yet they lie
to us to appease women [__] you're the
one that's not married what do you know
about what men want yeah you're doing
everything wrong apparently you have you
have no authority to speak about what
men want you're like the most
undesirable woman in the world
apparently every single favorite is
created for women she has missed you are
failing to attract a man yeah
when you're getting older every day
golly time is at second for Miss perley
grown men will try and convince me that
I'm oppressed
I will never try to convince you of that
I've Gotten Good at everything I've set
my mind to um
have evidence of contrary
my life is easier because I'm a woman I
have never been paid less than a man but
she has like one year of professional
yeah in the workplace and she's 26.
women that complain about this are lazy
entitled
good for you if you had an easy
experience like what do you want but
she's just spamming this like yeah
whatever her life doesn't mean that
that's what everybody's experience is
yeah another one has super wealthy
parents and Au pairs yeah
uh no one watched that WNBA
I played for 16 years and I don't watch
it
ladies either make it more entertaining
or stop complaining about the pay I
think she's lying about her athletic uh
prowess she said she was like near
professional I seen her I've seen her
shooting a ball around it's a lanky-ass
dork uncoordinated weirdo she is
straight up lying about her yeah in my
opinion I mean Jimmy maybe I mean she
could have played but no she said she
was near professional basketball and
volleyball
in college okay olive oil
olive oil
[Music]
I I gotta say you can see her shooting
hoops and doing uh volleyball on her
Channel and in my opinion she's a
[__] liar no shot
if you are not a professional athlete
sorry
WNBA players deserve less money stop
letting these delusional athletes bully
the men into paying for raises they
don't deserve the audacity of women who
have operated at a loss for a decade to
demand a raise okay all right
the WNBA
they're gone too far no your husband
isn't going to abuse you if you give him
all of the control in a relationship oh
that's comfortable okay
that's good news ladies it's just
abusing you because you're not giving
him enough control
you need to submit harder that is my bad
submit art if your husband is beating it
is because you are not submitting hard
it's because you talked back that's what
she's saying that is so insane for her
to say when she clearly has zero
experience with anything simple
Undateable [__] loser of a woman if
she hates her mom so much why doesn't
she just want her parents to divorce I
feel like that would have fixed this
whole problem wow that's a really really
good idea
you know that's that's definitely a big
part of this so if your parents divorce
maybe we would have had a happier
referral yeah that wouldn't be down this
red pill situation
she's the best though isn't she isn't
she folks um let's see top posts on the
subreddit about the debate lots of good
stuff here
oh yeah this subred was like I'm over
this this [__]
I get it Ethan interviewing another
picture wrote right-wing grifter I was
having a watch not knowing this person
who existed 15 minutes ago me losing
brain cells why do we look so unenthused
in this photo what was this
this is a behind the scenes yeah I think
we're doing we were on
is the cards we're opening the cards on
camera awesome yeah slavery according to
Pearl Davis
very funny
I live reaction to Pearl trying to form
a response
really that was her her too trying to
perform
another one joins The Fray yeah this is
a rough photo
another one joins Frey come on leave
Jeff alone
let's forget about Jeff this is her
family I understand why she's defending
slavery
Fair Point
right
this family's so white they have an
albino effect wherever they live it
cools the environment
because they reflect so much light back
in his face
that's right we've got all cold-blooded
animals a greenhouse effect no the
albino effect I'm thinking about
albino albino no albino
albino is that a thing
hold on I'll tell it to you
the Albedo effect
yeah look at you Mr educated
definition Albedo effect is the ability
of a service to reflects sunlight
off-white okay
well done well done therefore and you
know uh really uh ice covered areas it's
cooler because it reflects a lot of
light back thank you therefore Dan
Ethan's the smartest guy in the office
I've been trying to tell you that I'm
trying to make that claim
it's a Michael and uh Oscar you ever
heard of Albedo my friend
I know you've heard of libido got him
which everybody knows that word is a
common word
everybody knows what that means so it's
a pretty good joke I think once you kind
of get into the mechanics of it right
yeah cheers my dude
he is my dude love you no homo what the
[__] is that Zach
some guy dude what you're [__] with
me
love you my dude no homo love ya no homo
what is that that's gotta be something
you're blowing smoke up my ass cheers my
dude it's some said it it has to be yeah
I'm not familiar either
no homo
is it supposed to be easy
uh uh hey you want to know what a
[__] weirdo she is she kept talking
about how all women want to [__] Drake
even though he has a ton of sex partners
so this is under LinkedIn this is under
LinkedIn uh oh God she is she put on the
hazmats for this people he would
Drake even even Jesus can't save her man
so this is from her LinkedIn
or LinkedIn apparently yes you had this
like on her resume check it out oh Mark
phone
[Music]
I wonder why she only has one year of
experience
what is this doing online
she's looking for work
it's giving me the remember the girl
that the the way boom boom boom
everybody say way oh you remember that
girl
oh my God I gotta play that along with
her hold on
oh my God
everybody why is she always wearing red
because she's a Nazi
right now
looks similar to him
look at this bro that's her she grew up
everyone know where she's where this
girl went
[Laughter]
it's her she grow up
oh that was something everybody says way
up wayo
she did that like a whole bunch of times
this is this is internet Laura right
here this is important stuff I haven't
thought of this in 10 years yeah I
didn't know you guys were talking about
yeah this is this is awesome it's a
shame what happened to the way oh girl
she is the way she is the whale girl
anyway as we close this off here's Dave
Rubin getting absolutely bodied by Larry
King he died recently right yeah to the
[__] goat cheers my dude is that
Larry King it might be
uh gold nugget on the way out because
Larry King's The Go
yeah here you can see the utmost respect
that Larry David a seasoned journalist
with a lifelong of uh Larry King
so Larry David the Reuben show
does it usually sit on this side or the
other side I don't know this is how he
usually does it this is what shabibo he
was on the other side right it was a
different set he gave Ben his chair that
day that's what I'm watching I'm kidding
yeah well Ben was asking him questions
so is it kind of a weird format I don't
know maybe that is the same set and
you're right they were swapped yeah
interesting please Ben you take the good
seat uh Ben we brought you out a seat
that hasn't been sit sat in by a gay man
as you requested and I totally get that
love you no homo dude what the [__] is
that
is
cheers dude what is that love you know
homo who's saying that
do you do you guys know what the [__]
that is
brain
it's a powerful thing we'll latch on to
the most random thing and then it just
sticks with all of us it just becomes
like a random meme in the office I'm
behind on this one but love you my dude
no homo
all right so here's Larry David uh Larry
King The King showing nothing
the Reuben yeah not somebody said rip
Larry David she's dead
in the chat
we're gonna ban anybody that says that
watch out here it is and then we gotta
go out of Pennsylvania
Jake Javits of New York he's a distant
cousin of mine actually oh yeah great
man yeah great man
my
oh he's got a phone
all right let me show it again yeah show
us this phone
Samsung makes it I saw I visited that
company in Korea yes
Samsung me
he's awesome and it's ringing right now
look at him
dude he is the god hello
hey Cannon where are you
[Music]
oh you didn't have a game today
look at he's so cut
you know like he can't even make it
funny he just sits there so pathetic got
a doubleheader this coming Saturday
and it just I would like probably just
get on and walk off Larry
look at him he's trying to get him off
but he's such a [__]
oh he's not even he can't embrace the
moment it would be so funny if he did
I genuinely think he's just thinking
like God I'm gonna look like such a
[__] I'm gonna cut it out
yeah in fact they didn't cut it out
maybe that's the only explanation
well I'm doing David rubin's podcast now
his old ass on the phone the audience is
watching he gets his own shot to you
oh wow captain and you're starting
something you could do the attention
this may not have been a live stream oh
no it says live as it was okay so it was
live yeah no is it with Larry King live
isn't oh it's not Eric scroll down
it says it stream three years ago thank
God at least there's that I mean [__] if
he uploaded this himself my goodness he
wanted to do his own podcast thank god
he's a great kid all right Ken when am I
going to see it um tonight I'm tied up
tomorrow how are the kids
how about Friday night dude this is a
great moment Reuben all right own it
don't be such a [__] the night before
you double hit her
I'll be in both games
okay I'll be there
I love you Cannon
love you no homo
tomorrow what I love the idea of saying
no homo to your son I love you son
have fun at school
this is the most pathetic man alive
you're breaking news
that's tremendous that clip of Norm
Macdonald on The View when they try to
do this to producers were like they
wanted him to fake a pro uh oh yeah and
he's like he's like I can't do this this
is stupid yeah he called him out yeah
they give up for them
this is Larry David he knows what he's
doing is insane on the live show yeah
that's two pretty good respect for this
man Kinder miatican picture that Alex
medulla is going to be a star look how
cool
is there someone going for any angels to
the Red Sox
that's Ben Shapiro on the phone
he's like are you sitting in the gay
chair or the other one keep drinking the
water there rubbo wow
check Cannon you bring me great news
there's going to be a lot more Pearl
music soon because she's working on an
album oh that's exciting that's gonna be
wow Pearl is threatening to release him
oh yeah
over our heads
President Biden if you don't make
divorce illegal I'm dropping my album
this is a threat love you does anyone
call Dave Rubin Ruben the rube I believe
so many times is a very obvious pun
based off of business making sure I was
just giving you an answer just making
sure no need for the Sass no no not sass
just fast
I think I'm the first frankly I haven't
seen any of them all right we're at a
three hours and 40 minutes well thank
you everybody thank you to the
congratulations to a b
thank you cheers
we can talk about uh Tate on Monday
there might even be updates
there might be we may have
something potentially special on Monday
I don't know if we should announce it
though write it to me all right
call me call me on my resume
oh that's on Monday
let's save it okay so you don't feel
rushed to do it if you need more time or
something
no homo no home all right let's go all
right thank you for watching everybody
have a great weekend hopefully I don't I
don't have a terminal illness I'll let
you guys know
did your brother ever get back to us
Lena he must be working right now you
didn't tell him to take you tell him to
drop everything he was doing everything
he just sent a bunch of red explanation
points okay I'm kidding
here's how here's how much time he has
left yeah
all right guys see you on Monday have a
great weekend to everybody
God bless except you Pearl
thank you
cheers my dude
love ya no homo
[Applause]
[Music]